la présidente qui a du succès mais je
crains que j'aille de désillusion en
désillusion
bon mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer cette audition bien sûr nous
sommes dans le cadre de nos auditions
budgétaires et nous entendons
aujourd'hui monsieur marcénot ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire qui vient nous présenter le
projet de budget pour son ministère pour
2023 je vous précise comme d'habitude
que cette audition est diffusée en vidéo
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
et qu'elle sera disponible ensuite en
vidéo à la demande monsieur le ministre
c'est la première fois que la commission
des affaires économiques vous entend
même si nous avons déjà eu l'habitude de
travailler avec vous en tant que
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
pendant quatre ans et que depuis votre
nomination nous avons eu quelques sujets
nationaux mais aussi locaux nul doute
que mes collègues profiteront de cette
audition pour faire le tour de
l'actualité agricole elle est
extrêmement riche mise en oeuvre bloquée
des retenues d'eau crise inflationniste
crise énergétique conséquences de la
sécheresse et des incendies influenza à
Vière prédation du loup crise du bio
négociation commerciale à venir j'en
passe sûrement mais le menu est
appétissant je vous demanderai
d'ailleurs mes chers collègues d'essayer
de vous concentrer autant que possible
sur le budget mais nous sommes tellement
contents de vous avoir que voilà
monsieur le ministre vous nous présentez
donc ce soir un budget nominalement en
très forte hausse puisque la mission
agriculture alimentation forêt et
affaires rurale sa croix de 30% passant
de 3 à 3,9 milliards d'euros nous
aurions été ravis de pouvoir nous
féliciter avec vous de cette hausse si
elle ne s'expliquait pas essentiellement
par des mesures de périmètre sur les 880
millions de hausse 430 millions c'est à
dire que la moitié s'explique par la
simple budgétisation enfin simple par la
budgétisation de l'exonération des
cotisations sociales pour l'embauche des
travailleurs Lionel demandeur d'emploi
la fameuse fameuse Théodore auparavant
compensé à la sécurité sociale par
l'affection l'affectation pardon d'une
fraction de la TVA pour le reste le
programme de 106 sur la sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation augmente lui
de 7 % portée notamment par la mise en
oeuvre de la police unique de la
sécurité sanitaire des aliments
peut-être vous nous expliquerez vous
d'expliquerez nous nous enfin bref nous
aurons des explications je vais y
arriver en quelques mots sur la nature
de la restructuration que vous mettez en
oeuvre et surtout sur l'efficience
attendue parce que c'est un sujet que
nous avons traité
pas mal de fois ici au Sénat certaines
lignes en revanche peu onéreuses donc
qui passe comme ça un peu
inaperçu au profit de dispositif qui
avait démontré leur efficacité semble
être moins abondé que l'an passé et
Madame la rapporteur Françoise Ferrat en
citera quelques-unes en revanche le
programme 14 19 qui porte notamment sur
les 250 millions de crédits budgétaires
mis sur la table pour la réforme de
l'assurance récolte augmente de 21%. il
faut souligner bien sûr cet effort
budgétaire qui est notable qui découle
de la loi que nous avons voté ici même
si j'allais dire le compte n'est pas
entièrement et je laisserai bien sûr le
rapporteur le rend Duplomb revenir sur
ce point tout à l'heure dans les
quelques évolutions supplémentaires
n'ont pas voté par les députés mais
retenus par le gouvernement on trouve la
hausse attendue de 10 millions d'euros
en faveur de l'ONF concrétisant
l'engagement du gouvernement a consacré
plus de moyens à la défense des forêts
contre l'incendie mais Catherine mes
collègues bien sûr Anne-Catherine
Loisier et Olivier rickmann ne
manqueront pas de vous interroger à ce
propos nous venons il y a quelques
semaines de valider la nomination de
Madame étrichéquet et nous attendons
dans les prochains mois un plan de
profonde réorganisation de l'ONF car le
seul ajout budgétaire ne suffit pas
probablement à l'amélioration
souhaitable de l'efficience de l'ONF sur
les territoires vous l'avez compris
monsieur le ministre nous aimerions vous
entendre sur ces éléments structurants
du PLF au-delà de cette mission
budgétaire sur laquelle les trois
rapporteurs donc le rendu plomb François
se fera et Jean-Claude Tissot vous
questionneront plus en détail j'aurais
voulu vous entendre sur l'ensemble des
crédits portés par le ministère mais qui
échappe à la mission agriculture ces
montants sont considérables et donc il
nous manquent par conséquent d'un
panorama d'ensemble je pense en
particulier au plan de relance mais
aussi au plan France 2003 qui consacre
un million un milliard et demi d'euros
d'un côté de milliards pratiquement 3
milliards de l'autre j'aurais voulu
savoir si la en fait comment est-ce que
vous pilotez en lien avec France 2030
c'est ces crédits qu'en est-il en
particulier la mise en oeuvre du plan
entrepreneur du vivant du plan de
résilience Ukraine pouvez-vous nous
faire une synthèse et crédit débloquer
pour faire face aussi aux aléas
climatiques et économiques et nous dire
dans quelle mesure le plan France 200 3
joue son rôle de catalyseur permet-il
vraiment de dessiner l'agriculture de
demain par des investissements par
exemple dans la recherche ou la
robotique enfin si nous avons le temps
nous aimerions que vous nous présentiez
vos intentions et votre agenda pour les
prochains mois et je pense bientôt bien
sûr surtout à la loi d'orientation sur
le renouvellement agricole qui aura elle
aussi des implications budgétaires et
nous aimerions en connaître le périmètre
voilà monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse maintenant nous présenter votre
budget pour 2023 répondre à ses
premières questions après quoi je
donnerai la parole au rapporteur de la
commission pour être parfaitement
transparente le rend Duplomb Françoise
Ferrat et Franck Tissot Jean-Claude
Tussaud je pardon Jean-Claude
Tissot et je laisserai s'il le souhaite
Vincent Segoin et Patrice joli
rapporteur spéciaux de la commission des
finances prendre la parole s'il le
souhaite ils ont adopté leur rapport
hier puis naturellement aux collègues
voici le souhaiteront je vous conseille
donc d'utiliser notre cher boucle
WhatsApp pour ce pourquoi elle est faite
et non pas pour des digressions bizarres
du matin voilà merci beaucoup je vais
vous visser les bruits risque des
boucles WhatsApp de se tromper de
dessinateur merci Monsieur le monsieur
le ministre ne vous écoutons
merci madame la Présidente merci de
votre accueil madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier de m'avoir convié à venir de
ventre devant votre commission pour
présenter ce budget il me semble que
c'est un rendez-vous particulièrement
utile et notamment dans le contexte que
nous connaissons le contexte budgétaire
mais le contexte agricole vous l'avez un
peu évoqué actuellement l'aspect
stratégique de notre capacité à produire
pour nourrir a été de nouveau mise en
évidence par la guerre en Ukraine et les
crédits de cette mission revêtent par
conséquent une importance particulière
dans le moment que nous traversons pour
crédibiliser notre action mais au-delà
de ces grands bouleversements je
n'oublie pas pour commencer l'urgence
immédiate j'imagine que je serai
interrogé sur la question mais
les questions des coûts de l'énergie la
question des risques cela peut refaire
peser sur la continuité de l'activité
agricole et je suis en contact comme
vous le savez étroit avec le nombre de
filières pour nous citer que l'une
d'entre elles je pense à la filière
endive
pour les soutenir et suivre l'évolution
de leur situation essayez d'adapter les
dispositifs que nous avons déployés ou
que nous allons déployer à la réalité de
ces filières que vous connaissez la
première caractéristique pour en revenir
au budget d'abord de la mission que je
voudrais souligner devant vous c'est
l'augmentation substantielle de ces
crédits qui s'élève cette année à 5
milliards 987 millions d'euros pardon
c'est un milliard de plus par rapport à
l'année prochaine avec le plan de
relance et vous l'avez souligné madame
la Présidente avec France 2030 avec les
financements européens avec les
dispositifs fiscaux et sociaux ce sont
près de 26 milliards d'euros qui sont
alloués ou programmés pour le
développement de l'agriculture et de
l'agroalimentaire c'est dire si c'est
moyen sont importants c'est un budget
qui nous donne les moyens de financer
nos priorités pour bâtir notre
souveraineté alimentaire grâce à
l'engagement sans faille des agents du
ministère des Services des concentrés
des opérateurs qui viendront le traduire
concrètement cette augmentation de
crédit c'est surtout un signal fort à
mon sens pour ce premier budget du
quinquennat c'est un soutien très
concret et décisif avec l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme de l'assurance
récolte la prolongation du to d e le
maintien des financements dédiés à
l'indemnité compensatoire de handicap
naturel et pour continuer à dynamiser
notre enseignement agricole ou améliorer
notre politique forestière vous
permettrez d'ailleurs de commencer par
le soutien à la forêt que je
souhaiterais évoquer en premier lieu
devant vous parce que c'est un aspect
essentiel des crédits de cette mission
que je connais je connais le langage
vend du Sénat et de nombre d'entre vous
sur ce sujet avec les différents travaux
qui ont été réalisés par le Sénat ce
budget est celui d'un soutien appuyé à
notre politique forestière qui s'inscrit
dans la droite ligne des annonces
récentes du président de la République
sur l'objectif de renouvellement de 10%
de la forêt française d'ici 2030 pour
faire face au changement et aux
dérèglement climatique je serai
d'ailleurs prochainement dans un certain
nombre de départements pour traduire de
manière concrète en présentant la
feuille de route gouvernementale vous y
avez fait allusion madame la Présidente
pour la planification forestière et le
volet forestier de France nation vers
autour de quatre axes la prévention des
risques de feu
dans les forêts je réunirai
prochainement les acteurs de la mise en
oeuvre des obligations légales de
débroussaillant qui est l'un des sujets
avant le lancement de travaux plus
larges pour lutter contre les miettes de
la propriété forestière le renforcement
des moyens de l'ONF pour la lutte contre
les feux naissants et la DFCI se traduit
déjà concrètement dans ce budget avec
d'abord la suspension des réductions de
poste au sein de l'ONF et 10 millions
d'euros supplémentaires prévus dans
cette loi de finance auquel s'ajouteront
je lui dis dès à présent les 10 millions
supplémentaires qui ont été votés par
voie d'amendement et réintégrer à
l'intérieur du texte qui vous a été
transmis donc c'est 20 millions de plus
qu'aura l'ONF à sa disposition mais
comme vous l'avez dit on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en débattre ce n'est pas
seulement une question de moyens vous en
avez tout à fait raison deuxième axe
d'investissement dans les compétences
pour être à la hauteur du défi forestier
nous avons besoin d'attirer les vocation
de soutenir la formation et les
savoir-faire pour gérer durablement la
forêt il me semble que d'ailleurs le
point de la recherche est un point très
important dans cet aspect forestier dont
nous avons besoin de mieux éclairer nos
décisions publiques sur la question des
peuplements et des nouveaux peuplements
pour faire face aux dérèglement en
climatique le troisième axe c'est le
grand chantier de replantation de la
forêt française cela va permettre
d'amplifier le travail mise en oeuvre
par ce ministère depuis deux ans via le
plan France relance et la mesure de
renouvellement forestier qui a permis de
reconstituer près de 50000 hectares de
forêt et il nous faudra d'abord
structurer pour cela et c'est un élément
très important de la stratégie notre
filière de graines et de plans enfin
dernier axe le fer filière comme l'a
évoqué le président de la République
c'est moins des aspects budgétaires mais
ça suscitera peut-être des questions
voilà la politique forestière est sans
entrer dans tous les détails vos
questions vous permettront sans doute de
le faire je dois évoquer trois axes
forts de cette mission le premier c'est
crédit nous permet d'agir en soutien aux
filières et aux exploitations agricoles
j'ai d'ailleurs pris connaissance avec
un grand intérêt du rapport qui a publié
sortie Sénat sur la compétitivité de la
ferme France la compétitivité est une
dimension très importante pour assurer
évidemment notre souveraineté c'est par
exemple pour cela que nous avons réalisé
des investissements massifs avec France
relance 1,6 milliards d'euros et France
2030 qui sous ses différents aspects
couvrent près de 2,9 milliards d'euros
mais j'aurais l'occasion à la suite de
cette intervention peut-être de le
détailler si vous le souhaitez madame la
Présidente mélenchez de la souveraineté
alimentaire suppose me semble-t-il de
essayer de maintenir ce qu'on a fait en
montée de gamme mais par ailleurs de
faire face à aux entrées de gamme parce
que c'est sans doute là que nous avons
des choses à corriger c'est le tout le
sens d'ailleurs en tout cas une grande
partie du sens du rapport au sénatorial
que vous avez produit c'est le revenu
agricole qui est aussi en est la clé de
voûte et dans cette logique il nous faut
produire plus mais aussi produire mieux
et assumer des transitions écologiques
et sociales pour créer de nouveaux
débouchés j'en viens à la réforme de
l'assurance récolte qui est un élément
structurant non pas seulement du budget
mais aussi deux systèmes assurantiels le
français c'était attendu depuis très
longtemps et grâce au travail qui a été
fait au Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale
nous sommes parvenus un texte
nous sommes aux côtés des agriculteurs
pour faire face aux effets du changement
climatique et d'ailleurs le PFR présenté
récemment confirme notre soutien en
venant abonder des dispositifs
d'accompagnement sur l'assurance se
récolte dire simplement que c'est le
produit du travail du varen de l'eau qui
avait évoqué trois piliers le premier
c'est un système assurantiel
complètement refondé parce que
objectivement il allait dans le mur
contenu de ce que sont la multiplication
des aléas en volume et en géographie et
deux premiers éléments c'était celui-là
deuxième élément c'était d'accompagner
les transitions agricoles pour faire
face aux dérèglement climatique et ça
c'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire
dans France relance et que nous
souhaitons poursuivre dans France 2030
et puis troisième élément c'était
l'accès à l'eau qui est un élément
déterminant de la stratégie que nous
devons mettre en oeuvre pour faire face
aux dérèglement climatique et ça
suscitera j'imagine quelques questions
afin de financer ce nouveau système
l'effort de l'État fait plus que doublé
il atteint 256 millions d'euros qui
s'ajoutent au 185 millions euros de
crédit européen et au 120 millions
d'euros de taxes affectées avec un
doublement des contributions des
cotisants c'est à dire des agriculteurs
il faut le saluer aussi soit un total de
560 millions en première année avec une
trajectoire que nous voulons atteindre à
600 millions d'euros c'est celle qui
avait été annoncé et la capacité à
pouvoir aller jusqu'à 680 millions
d'euros dans le cas où la réforme
connaîtra un succès plus ample encore
que ce que nous souhaitons ce nouveau
système doit s'accompagner par ailleurs
du nécessaire adaptation des filières je
l'ai dit et donc c'est un des éléments
de la lutte ou de l'accompagnement ou
dérèglement climatique mais ce n'est pas
le seul élément et c'est pas sur cette
seule base que nous devons faire
deuxième élément la Pâque sans citer
l'ensemble des avancées de la pack je
voudrais évoquer le soutien au
développement de l'agriculture
biologique avec un objectif de 18% pour
y parvenir les soutiens dédiés sont ont
été augmentés 36% par rapport à la
précédente programmation soit 340
millions d'euros la dotation du fond
d'avenir vous est stabilisée à 5
millions d'euros supplémentaires suite à
l'examen en première lecture je voudrais
également mentionner deux avancées
majeures qui ils vont avoir leurs
conséquences la conditionnalité sociale
qui vise à respecter mieux des règles
dans le domaine du droit du travail et
le droit à l'erreur qui est un élément
important de la crédibiliser et de la
confiance qu'on doit réinstaurer entre
l'administration et les agriculteurs ça
suscitera peut-être là aussi quelques
questions 3e élément la prolongation du
Théodose vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente pour 3 ans elle est
déterminante pour les activités
fortement utilisatrices de main d'oeuvre
saisonnière et pour lesquelles le coût
du travail est un enjeu important ça a
été souvent souligné par des rapports de
compétitivité enfin les moyens je ne
veux pas les oublier de l'outre-mer les
crédits du somme ont été maintenus comme
le budget européen du poséi pour
répondre notamment aux enjeux
d'autonomie alimentaire des territoires
ultramarins qui nous reste à construire
nous avons par ailleurs sensiblement
augmenté le budget à lui au filières
sucres de la réunion avec deux 19
millions d'euros supplémentaires
deuxième axe de notre action assurer la
sécurité sanitaire comme vous l'avez
évoqué ces 7% d'augmentation des moyens
par rapport à 2022 trois éléments
principaux un budget complémentaire de
9,4 millions euros à compter de 2023
pour garantir la mise en oeuvre de la
loi santé animale nous allons poser les
jalons d'une sécurité sanitaire
européenne qui constituera à terme un
avantage compétitif pour notre
agriculture nous allons également
fortement renforcer nos contrôles et la
surveillance des dangers sanitaires et
s'ils sont nombreux sans les citer tous
je vois bien ce qui se développe autour
de l'influence de la Vierge de la
bruxellose enfin les crédits de cette
mission permettront la mise en place de
la police unique en charge de la
sécurité sanitaire dont mon ministère
sera désormais responsable c'est une
réponse forte aux préoccupations
légitimes de nos concitoyens parfois à
la suite de scandale sanitaire enfin
dernier axe porté par le ministère celui
de la préparation de l'avenir à travers
ses crédits ceux de la mission
enseignement scolaire que j'aurai
l'occasion de présenter la semaine
prochaine devant la commission de la
culture au Sénat le plafond du casdar
est maintenu à 126 millions d'euros mais
j'ai obtenu de bénéficier de
de l'excédent de recettes 2022 qui
devrait représenter 17 millions d'euros
ce qui est un débat assez récurrent avec
Bercy avec Bercy comme vous le savez et
prenez-en cette année donc
et ça devrait donc représenter 17
millions d'euros si tu permettras de
renforcer la recherche appliquée et le
développement pour favoriser l'adoption
d'innovation et de changement de
pratique sautant particulier la
transition écologique agroécologique je
l'ai souvent dit pas d'interdiction sans
solution
et de ce point de vue là les moyens de
la recherche des moyens de
l'accompagnement au développement sont
nécessaires pour aller dans les filières
on voit bien qu'on peut se retrouver
face à des impacts techniques nous
investissons également en souten la
formation grâce aux moyens consacrés à
l'enseignement et à la recherche qui
hors dépenses de personnels s'élèvent en
2023 699 millions d'euros en hausse de
4%, les crédits de cette mission vont
aussi nous permettre la revalorisation
de 4% des bourses pour critères sociaux
de la prime d'internat l'élargissement
de la bourse au mérite l'amélioration
des capacités d'accueil de nos
établissements et de nos écoles
vétérinaires notamment pour les élèves
en situation de handicap nous avions des
retards dans notre périmètre et tout
cela va nous permettre d'amplifier la
dynamique constatée dans l'enseignement
agricole enfin je voudrais conclure sur
un sujet essentiel pour notre
souveraineté alimentaire c'est celui du
renouvellement des générations
le 9 septembre dernier le président de
la République a annoncé les axes de la
future loi d'orientation et d'avenir
agricole l'orientation la transmission à
l'installation la transition et
l'adaptation pour faire face aux
changements climatique et notamment par
l'innovation une large concertation va
s'ouvrir simplement vous donner les
termes de cette concentration c'est une
concertation qui sera menée au niveau
national et au niveau régional dans un
partenariat qui sera celui des Chambres
d'Agriculture des régions et de l'état
parce que me semble que ces trois
acteurs pour des raisons d'ailleurs
différentes les chambres parce qu'elles
sont des opérateurs de la massification
des pratiques qu'on a à mettre en oeuvre
et de très bons observateurs c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire de ce qu'est la
réalité agricole et puis l'État et les
régions parce qu'ils se sont les deux
acteurs de la transition qui peut être
menée au travers leur différents
dispositifs d'intervention avec une
logique et il y aura peut-être des
questions qui est de faire en sorte que
nous réfléchissons ce renouvellement de
génération comme vous le savez c'est
plus de la moitié ou près de la moitié
des agriculteurs qui se situation de
pouvoir partir à la retraite dans les 10
ans qui viennent c'est donc près de 200
000 agriculteurs qui vont partir à la
retraite et donc nous avons besoin de
les installer non pas dans quelque chose
qui soit simplement une transmission
reprise une transmission transition pour
s'assurer que nous les installons bien
dans des conditions qui leur permettront
sous le régime de dérèglement climatique
et de dérèglement d'autres natures de
pouvoir s'installer dans des conditions
qui assurent la durabilité des systèmes
sur laquelle on va les installer je sais
d'ailleurs que votre commission des
affaires économiques du Sénat il
répondra une part active avec un
objectif que nous partageons largement
celui de garantir à tous nos
agriculteurs un système viable au
service de notre souveraineté mais sans
renouvellement de génération je le
répète il n'y aura pas de souveraineté
agricoles et alimentaire possible voilà
les éléments
de préambule un peu long peut-être
madame la Présidente que je voulais
faire sur cette question budgétaire et
ça suscitera sans doute un certain
nombre de questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vu
du nombre d'inscrits ça suscite déjà des
questions Laurent Duplomb ensuite
Françoise Ferrat et ensuite Jean-Claude
Tissot
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'aurais envie de reprendre une
métaphore qui est connue de la plupart
d'entre nous qui dit l'arbre qui cache
la forêt en fait c'est le principe de
regarder à travers un arbre et de ne
plus voir la forêt qui est derrière en
quelque sorte et de façon plus claire
c'est une certaine forme de manque
d'objectivité alors il est vrai que
l'arbre qui cache la forêt c'est les 900
millions d'euros de plus que vous
inscrivez cette année au budget qui
pourrait laisser penser que enfin
nous avons compris la problématique de
l'agriculture française et bien
malheureusement monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de faire quelques
critiques par rapport à cela mais aussi
à la fin de mon propos de vous faire une
proposition
les quelques critiques c'est que tout
simplement quand on parle d'assurance
récolte
si on veut créer ce que doit faire
l'assurance récolte c'est à dire une
forme de confiance avec les agriculteurs
il faut obligatoirement leur donner les
moyens d'avoir confiance les moyens
d'avoir confiance étaient déjà d'avoir
un texte qui soit partagé il a été un
peu au forceps mais il l'a été ce qu'il
faut derrière c'est après avoir pris des
engagements dans l'hémicycle les
traduire dans les actes aujourd'hui
c'est presque le cas on attend encore
les derniers décrets il reste quand même
la commission départementale d'expertise
pour éviter les problèmes que nous
rencontrons et que vous rencontrez
sûrement cette année au niveau des
calamités mais il n'en reste pas moins
vrai que le fait de ne pas inscrire un
montant précis qui correspond à la
réalité de la politique que vous voulez
mettre en place ne crée pas à mon sens
une forme de confiance vous demandez
bien les 120 millions d'euros d'efforts
aux agriculteurs mais vous n'êtes pas
capable d'écrire les 680 millions
d'euros dans le budget qui mériteraient
d'être écrit parce que tout simplement
il correspondrait à la réalité de que
vous avez fini par accepter c'est à dire
les les quatre taux importants c'est à
dire le 20% de franchise les 70% de
subvention les 30 et 50% d'intervention
de l'État ça permettrait d'avoir
vis-à-vis du monde agricole une certaine
forme de respect de ces engagements qui
se traduisent par un écrit ça veut pas
dire que pour autant vous les consommiez
mais vous auriez eu la possibilité de
retranscrire ces crédits à la fin s'il
n'avait pas été consommé donc je pense
que c'est pas obligatoirement la
meilleure façon de prendre les choses le
deuxième élément c'est exactement la
même chose c'est le to d e le président
de la République au salon de
l'agriculture annonce une pérennisation
alors c'est vrai qu'avec le président de
la République comme au discours de
Rungis quand on le relie aujourd'hui il
faut faire attention aux mots parce que
tous les mots ont un sens et que la
difficulté dans la langue française
c'est que parfois le sens entre celui
qui les prononce et celui qui les écoute
pour avoir une différence de consonance
et c'est vrai que dans les discours du
président de la République cette forme
de en même temps qu'on a appris à
connaître se traduit souvent par les
mots c'est vrai que le Président de la
République lors du Salon de
l'Agriculture a dit qu'il voulait
pérenniser le Théodore parce que c'était
un bon système pourquoi ne pas l'avoir
fait monsieur le ministre c'est bien
d'inscrire dans ces 900 millions d'euros
supplémentaires 430 millions qui
proviennent en fait d'une transfert de
budget ou d'un transfert de ligne
budgétaire mais pourquoi ne pas l'avoir
pérennisé en même temps pourquoi avoir
attendu que ça soit un député à
l'Assemblée nationale en plus du groupe
LR qui propose de le reprolonger pendant
trois ans et que ce soit le Sénat pas
plus tard qu'avant-hier qui le périnise
complètement pourquoi ne pas donner un
message clair à nos agriculteurs qui
n'attendent que ça le même sujet c'est
la police alimentaire j'étais favorable
et je l'ai dit plein de fois à votre
prédécesseur je pense qu'il faut qu'on
ait une police alimentaire qui permet de
faire respecter les clauses miroir mais
là aussi c'est pareil quand les
personnes que vous allez récupérer de la
dgccr et les personnes que vous allez
créer pour cette police dans la DGL vous
ne vous les mettez uniquement dans les
départements je ne vois pas comment dans
les départements vous allez traiter le
problème des produits qui arrivent
importer qui ne respectent pas nos
normes c'est un Rungis et sur les
frontières qu'il faut les mettre c'est
pas à venir embêter et encore plus
contrôler la problématique de nos
départements et de ceux qui savent à la
tâche tous les jours alors la réalité
tout ça c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait
aujourd'hui on n'a pas tout compris on
n'a pas compris que derrière la
problématique de ce budget nous avons
une suradeministration en France et
beaucoup trop de capacité à
surtransposer cette sur administration
elle est arrivée à faire traduire pour
les agriculteurs une différence c'est
que pendant des années par le progrès
matériel et autres on a pu permettre de
baisser la problématique de du du de la
pénibilité du travail physique mais
aujourd'hui on l'a remplacé par une
pénibilité du travail psychologique et
d'ailleurs à ce sujet je vais vous
donner un exemple monsieur le ministre
parce que ça il faut que vous le garder
il me reste deux petits points là le
premier c'est cet exemple vous
connaissez pas monsieur Cyril Testud il
est agriculteur sur la commune du
département juste à côté du mien
l'Ardèche on me condamnera pas d'avoir
pris un exemple de chez moi du lac
d'Issarlès qui parce que alors qu'il
coche la case correspondant à l'unité
qu'on se passe la triste des handicaps
naturels dans sa déclaration pack depuis
15 ans a oublié cette année de la cocher
un oubli une case coût 13950 euros qui
ne vont pas lui être payé 13950 euros
c'est ça la suradeministration française
qu'on ne peut plus accepter alors la
proposition monsieur le ministre je vous
en fais une j'ai reçu la totalité de la
restauration hors domicile ils me disent
qu'aujourd'hui l'inflation galopante des
produits alimentaires qui risquent de
dépasser les 15% à partir du mois
d'avril de l'année prochaine fait
qu'aujourd'hui le coût d'un repas dans
une cantine coûterait 40 centimes de
plus ces mêmes représentants quand je
leur pose la question de tout ce que
nous avons voté depuis quatre ans me
disent qu'entre égalim 1 et Gallim 2
avec climat résilience toutes les
contraintes qu'on a mis à la
restauration hors domicile c'est
l'équivalent de 20 centimes alors je
vous fais une proposition monsieur le
ministre qui nous coûte rien au budget
de la France il faut détendre cette
situation il faut savoir dans une
situation où comme le dit le président
de la République dans une économie de
guerre et bien arrêté de mettre toutes
ces injonctions laisser la possibilité à
la liberté d'entreprendre et limiter
limiter de plus plus nos injonctions
contradictoires qui nous mènent dans le
mur et qui font qu'à un moment ou un
autre nous constaterons les dégâts trop
tard merci Laurent
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues à mon tour de prendre la
parole pour vous parler dans la suite de
deux rapports dont j'étais coin
rapporteur de la réforme de la police
sanitaire unique et du soutien aux
agriculteurs en difficulté en
particulier dans le monde de l'élevage
sur le premier point on ne peut que se
réjouir de la mise en place progressive
d'ici au 1er janvier 2024 de la police
sanitaire unique qui était une demande
ancienne de notre commission dans
plusieurs rapports je pense à celui de
Laurent Duplomb sur le sésame à l'oxyde
d'éthylène ou plus récemment à notre
rapport transpartisan sur l'information
du consommateur avec Fabien gay et
Florence bad tricks compta notre
commission a appelé à clarifier la
répartition des compétences entre
Direction Générale de l'Alimentation et
direction générale de la concurrence et
de la répression des fraudes voilà qui
sera chose faite et votre ministère
obtient pour exercer sa nouvelle mission
la création de 90 ETP ainsi que le
transfert de 60 UTP de la DGCCRF
seulement cette réforme ne puisse pas la
problématique de la sécurité sanitaire
des aliments comme l'ont appelé les
drames heureusement rares et isolés de
cette année buttoni Kinder etc tout
d'abord faisons remarquer que la DGCCRF
disposait de 100 ETP et de plus pour
effectuer les mêmes missions une partie
non négligeable des contrôles sera
délégué par la DGL à des prestataires
privés des prestataires privés ce qui
fait craindre une qualité disparate de
ses contrôles vos services nous disent
que cette délégation permettra aux
équipes de se concentrer sur les
activités à plus forte valeur ajoutée
mais monsieur ministre n'est-ce pas là
un aveu que les contrôles ne sont pas
encore pleinement pris au sérieux dans
notre pays alors qu'un œil est visé
expérimenté permettrait bien souvent de
détecter ce que ne croyez pas détectable
pouvez-vous donc nous rassurer sur le
fait que cette délégation dont on
comprend qu'elle est faite pour des
raisons budgétaires ne signifiera pas la
perte de compétences
par ailleurs nous nous inquiétons que la
pression du contrôle ne soit pas exercée
au bon endroit à cause d'un mauvais
diagnostic à cet instant permettez-moi
de faire appel à vous souvenir de classe
de français et de littérature et un peu
à la manière de la Toinette de Molière
qui grimait en médecin rappelez-vous
voici faire le poumon le poumon vous
dise ce petit nom avoir dans le poumon
d'une cause des tourments d'argan le
fameux malade imaginaire
ce mauvais diagnostic nous continuons de
le poser chez nos producteurs nous
transformateurs nous distributeurs et
nous restaurateurs des coupables alors
que le maillon faible de la protection
des consommateurs c'est le contrôle des
dorés importés le rang vient de
l'évoquer à l'instant en clair nous
voudrions que les effectifs que vous
souhaitez déployer dans les départements
soit un peu plus à Rungis à contrôler
nos importations plutôt que pardonner
moi cette formule quasiment triviale sur
le dos de nos professionnels or en la
matière les compétences restent éclatées
entre les douanes et vos services et il
me semble que cela ne peut que nuire à
l'efficience des contrôles comment
Monsieur le Ministre comptez-vous
renforcer la coordination entre les
douanes et vos services et va-t-on
réussir un jour à muscler pour de bons
avec une police aux frontières digne de
ce nom les contrôles des importations en
coopération avec nos voisins européens
permettez-moi cette instinct monsieur le
ministre de vous poser une question sur
les inquiétudes suscitées par les
coupures d'électricité pour les filières
périssables lors de votre déplacement au
salon de l'alimentation vous avez assuré
que l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire
seront prioritaires en cas de coupure
d'électricité cet hiver il est impératif
de protéger nos entreprises de ces
secteurs notamment les filières
périssables que ce soit le lait la
viande les fruits et légumes qu'une sur
les frais pas de cette piqûre
d'électricité alors Monsieur ministre
vous avez évoqué les crédits dédiés tout
à l'heure mais sur le terrain est-ce que
des instructions en ce sens ont été
transmises au préfet pour s'assurer
qu'aucune coupure d'électricité ne
vienne porter un coup potentiellement
fatale aux filières de doré périssables
et enfin je ne peux pas conclure sans
dire un mot de la dramatique non non
j'ai raté quelque chose pardon monsieur
le ministre
ah oui tu m'as perturbé madame la
Présidente
ah voilà le sujet tellement à cœur deux
minutes madame la Présidente autre motif
d'inquiétude c'est celui primordial de
la situation des agriculteurs en
détresse une feuille de route a été
publiée en novembre 2021 nourri
notamment par le rapport que nous avons
produit Henri Cabanel et moi et un an
après en raison du caractère transversal
des mesures nous manquons cruellement de
visibilité sur les traductions
budgétaires de cette feuille de route
passer l'an dernier de 30 à 42 millions
d'euros éclatés en diverses actions
cette année au programme et même mission
seulement j'aimerais bien que ce soit
pas un coup de com où en est-on de la
mise en oeuvre de cette feuille de route
et je constate que les crédits de
paiement de l'aide à la relance des
exploitations agricoles qui avaient été
doublées l'an dernier sont en perte de
vitesse 5,2 contre 7,100 millions
d'euros je remarque pourtant avec
satisfaction que la commission des
affaires économiques de l'Assemblée
nationale
à effectuer un focus thématique sur leur
service de remplacement faisant sienne
des recommandations que nous avions
formulées avec Henri Cabanel pour le
rendre plus attractif pour les
exploitants nous sommes favorables à
l'augmentation de la citation via le
crédit d'impôts en complément de cette
intervention fiscale quels autres outils
voyez-vous pour un augmenter
l'attractivité tant du côté des
agriculteurs que du côté des agents
remplaçants en somme monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous donner une
vision d'ensemble sur cette feuille de
route et nous rassurer sur le fait que
son ambition est maintenue la
mobilisation est-elle bien générale au
sein des services de l'État je pense par
exemple à l'ofb dont les contrôles
stress tellement nos agriculteurs qui
sont arrivés comme cela a été
malheureusement le cas récemment à
commettre le pire ces crucial pour notre
agriculture et en particulier pour notre
élevage qui a beaucoup souffert ces
derniers temps
un petit mot sur justement sur l'aspect
vétérinaire dont nous étions félicité
l'an dernier que les stages tutorés
bénéficient d'un financement
satisfaisant on constate cette année une
baisse de près d'un quart des crédits de
paiement pour un dispositif pourtant de
bon sens et peut coûter permettant de
lutter contre les déserts vétérinaires
comment justifier vous cette baisse
monsieur le ministre enfin je termine
mais je ne peux pas conclure sans dire
un mot de la dramatique crise de
l'influence à vierge qui a coûté plus
d'un milliard d'euros à l'État sur la
saison 2021 à 2002 répartit en 300
millions d'euros d'aide sanitaire et 800
dettes économiques rapportés à ce
milliard la ligne budgétaire d'un
million d'euros relative à la
vaccination me semble bien peu abonder
je comprends que les verrous
développement de la vaccination ne sont
pas uniquement budgétaires mais
administratif mais n'y aurait-il pas un
moyen de donner un coup de pouce à cet
outil indispensable la prévention je
vous remercie
merci Françoise je vous presse un peu
parce qu'il y a énormément de questions
Jean-Claude Tissot merci madame la
Présidente je vais
quand même malgré tout faut dire les
choses bien sûr qu'on a le ministre bien
écoutez merci de m'avoir écouté non
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues je vais
pour ma part être assez succinct mais
monsieur le ministre nous interrogé sur
plusieurs aspects importants de votre
action les forêts confronté à de
nombreux défis la recherche
indispensable pour assurer l'évolution
de notre modèle et enfin la question de
l'enseignement qui doit être le
principal moteur à mon sens du
renouvellement des pratiques et des
générations dans les années à venir tout
d'abord après une année marquée comme on
sait tous ici par une triste vague des
feux de forêt il est de notre devoir de
ne plus traiter cet enjeu à la légère et
d'avoir une réflexion nouvelle sur ces
espaces et sur cette filière
la question du renouvellement forestier
et donc un sujet majeur à ce stade
avez-vous une estimation du surplus
nécessaire au renouvellement forestier à
la suite des feux de cet été est-ce
qu'un premier bilan des aides consacré
renouvellement forestiers a pu être
réalisé et de manière plus concrète
c'est feu qui ont dévasté des dizaines
de milliers d'hectares en France durant
l'été 2022 doivent nous amener à
repenser les forêts et le mode de
gestion des forêts la question centrales
finalement comment devons-nous replanter
pour avoir des forêts adaptées au
changement climatiques plus durable et
moins un risque pour les plans sur le
plan des incendies est-ce qu'une
réflexion est engagée au sein de votre
ministère à ce sujet notamment sur les
questions de mixité au sein des forêts
thématiques particulièrement documentées
il y a de la littérature autant qu'on
qu'on ait le temps de la lire de plus le
président de la République a annoncé
vouloir planter un milliard d'arbres
d'ici 2032 avez-vous une estimation de
cette nouvelle à grande annonce
je poursuis rapidement par les moyens et
les effectifs de l'ONF qui suscitent
logiquement toutes les attentions selon
les trajectoires établies dans le
contrat état ONF 2021 2025 ajusté les
effectifs de l'ONF auraient dû diminuer
de 80 postes en 2023 les récentes
annoncent gouvernementales
confirmés dans votre intervention à
l'Assemblée nationale merci dernier
semble indiquer un renoncement à la
suppression de ses postes aussi Monsieur
le Ministre est-ce que le contrat état
wenf 2021-2025 et maintenu malgré ce
récent revirement de situation si oui ne
serait-il pas plus logique de revoir ce
contrat qui continue de prévoir des
suppressions de poste dans le contexte
actuel traversé par les forêts enfin
nous aurions aimé savoir plus
précisément ce que permettre rond de
financer des 10 millions supplémentaires
accordés à l'ONF en dehors des 3,3
millions fléchés sur la création des 60
postes alors qu'une affectation des
moyens centrés sur l'agence DFCI
d'Aix-en-Provence par la zone sud est
évoquée il apparaît et là mes collègues
vont certainement dire la même chose que
moi il serait souhaitable d'avoir une
plus globale au bénéfice de l'ensemble
des territoires forestiers nous l'avons
vu cet été la prévention des incendies
ne concerne plus seulement le sud de la
France la multiplication des épisodes de
sécheresse et la hausse continue des
températures concernent l'ensemble des
territoires l'ensemble de nos
territoires ces critères doivent être à
mon sens doivent être prises en compte
pour assurer une juste répartition de la
réflexion et là je répartition des
moyens ensuite concernant la recherche
agricole j'ai interrogé à de nombreuses
reprises vos différents prédécesseurs
sur la question cadar qui nous occupent
toutes les années malheureusement les
années se suivent et se ressemblent à ce
sujet alors le on en est discuter
longuement lors des auditions hier le
produit de l'attaque sur le chiffre
d'affaires des exploitations agricoles
affectées au compte d'affectation
spéciale développement agricole et rural
est toujours estimé à 126 millions
d'euros c'est-à-dire exactement au même
montant que l'année dernière malgré le
dépassement systématique de ces recettes
prévisionnels qui a qui a visionne qui
approche les 140 millions et malgré
cette année une inflation qui est
synonyme finalement puisqu'on est à 126
millions qu'on l'année dernière d'une
diminution des moyens en constant vos
services nous ont indiqué hier qu'un
compromis avait été trouvé avec Bercy
pour maintenir ce compte d'affectation
spéciale et que les montants qui se
trouveraient au-dessus du plafond serait
mobilisé pour des actions de type casse
d'art monsieur le ministre ces accords
ministériels ne sont pas suffisants face
à la multiplication de ces enjeux
auxquels doivent faire face la recherche
agricole et depuis plusieurs années nous
portons une simple demande
l'augmentation du plafond du casse d'air
au niveau réel des cotisations des
paysans puisque ce sont eux qui mettent
au pot qui osent dire et nous vous
redemandons très clairement une
transparence totale parce que là c'est
un peu nébuleux je ne mets pas en doute
la bonne volonté de vos services mais
ces débuts de notre part en tant que
parlementaire de comprendre les rôles
comment sont gérés les les reliquats des
dernières années maintenant justement
du casse d'art
alors que les instituts techniques sont
obligés de redoubler d'inventivité pour
trouver des moyens et des techniques
adaptés au changement climatiques ils
ont besoin plus que jamais de pouvoir de
programmer de leurs recherches sur
plusieurs années vous imaginez bien sans
l'épée sans avoir une sans arrêt une
épée de Damoclès sur l'arrêt d'un
financement de façon plus générale il
convient de s'assurer que les instituts
de recherche et je pense en particulier
à l'inrae puis s'exercer leur mission
malgré la hausse des charges qu'il
subisse comme tout le monde pouvez-vous
nous dire si les évolutions sont prévues
pour en tenir compte et pour tenir
compte de leur situation et leur
permettre aussi un fonctionnement normal
de leur activité s'agissant enfin
nationalement agricole madame la
Présidente bientôt terminé nous
aimerions que vous reveniez plus
précisément sur des spécificités du
budget relatif à l'enseignement agricole
parmi les moyens supplémentaires
affectés à l'enseigne à cet enseignement
lequel relève de la hausse générale du
budget de l'éducation et lesquels sont
spécifiques à l'agriculture c'est
important pour qu'on sache pour conclure
sur une note un peu plus politique sur
cette thématique je considère que nous
devons réellement nous poser la question
du modèle agricole qui est enseignée
dans les différents établissements face
à la multiplication des difficultés et
des questionnements environnementaux
sécheresse gestion de l'eau utilisation
des intrants etc et face à une
problématique propre au monde agricole
en jeu de la transmission gestion des
exploitations et de l'artificialisation
face au tentations et on en a parlé
longuement les semaines dernière
d'installation énergétique je reviendrai
pas sur sujet là l'enseignement doit
traiter l'ensemble de ces enjeux pour
avoir des agricultrices et des
agriculteurs formés et prêtes à
affronter ces différents défis enfin une
toute dernière question qui est issue
lors des échanges d'hier au soir d'hier
après-midi hier soir tard dans
l'après-midi avec vos directions
générales de la performance économique
environnementale des entreprises il nous
a été indiqué que alors peut-être que
j'ai pas compris mais ça vous permettra
peut-être de dire que j'ai mal compris
donc du coup vous allez nous dire que la
bonne le bon la bonne méthode voilà il
était indiqué que les aides
compensatoires à l'explosion des
factures énergétiques pour les
exploitations agricoles sont uniquement
calculées à
postes dans un pas longtemps pourtant à
cause de la très forte hausse des coûts
énergétiques qui concernent les filières
variées de l'élevage des poulailler
porcheries etc à la production
nécessitant du froid le stockage des
pommes entre autres les endives etc
certains exploitants ne vont pas prendre
le risque et moi à la limite j'ai
encourage après certaines personnes ne
pas prendre le risque de démarrer leur
production ou une bande de poulet enfin
vous connaissez le système pour pas
mettre en péril soit l'ensemble
exploitation soit être absolument sûr
aujourd'hui avec les éléments donc qui
ont qu'ils ont leur possession d'être
infaillite dans 6 mois c'est absolument
obligatoire puisque le coup le produit
ne couvrira pas le coût de production
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre est-ce qu'une
réflexion est engagée et je vous dis
solennellement parce que là c'est
vraiment du de la vraie vie vous
permettre est-ce que oui est-ce qu'une
réflexion est engagée pour permettre un
mécanisme par anticipation du coup ne
pas attendre N+1 qui soulagerait
directement les agriculteurs voilà j'ai
été un petit peu long mais merci madame
la Présidente de m'avoir laissé le temps
en général quand on promet d'être court
c'est mauvais signe
donc trois sénateurs trois styles mais
beaucoup de questions et je vais vous et
je vais vous laisser répondre déjà au
rapporteur et ensuite je passerai la
parole à l'ensemble des autres
intervenants
je vais essayer d'y répondre en essayant
d'être long ce qui me permettra
peut-être d'être court
d'abord je voudrais répondre au sénateur
du plomb qui a beaucoup pleuré à la fois
sur le rapport qu'il a fait sur
l'assurance récolte puisque vous avez
été alors disait c'était le fruit un peu
d'un dialogue qui avait été compliqué
oui c'est un débat parlementaire que
j'ai trouvé moi j'étais pas tout à fait
au poste que j'occupe aujourd'hui mais
qui était utile parce que ça permettait
de confronter des points de vue je pense
qu'il y a des choses qui ont été ils
pouvaient naître des ambiguïtés du
je le dis très franchement de ce qui
était la CNT à la vérité même si vous
dites au forceps on s'est absolument
aligné sur ce qui était plutôt les
préconisations du Sénat y compris sur le
fameux règlement omnibus qui permet de
dire les choses donc de ce point de vue
là les choses sont pointées non attendez
j'ai bien vu que c'était pas votre
question mais comme vous avez dit que ça
avait été difficile de vous disiez c'est
presque qu'on a eu c'est pas presque
qu'on a eu c'est totalement ce que vous
avez eu dans la réglementation donc
autant se le dire j'ai bien noté votre
question j'y viens
et puis par ailleurs il y a des choses
dont on savait qu'elle nécessite un
dialogue entre les filières alors tout
va bien jusqu'à ce que on fasse
rencontrer les filières ou parfois les
avis ne sont pas de même nature même si
tout le monde rentre avec les mêmes
intentions et arrivant en cours de ce
cet épisode j'ai pu découvrir à quel
point ça pouvait être intéressant à
regarder et moi j'ai fait en sorte en
plus de ne pas nourrir les querelles
entre les filières ce que je pense qu'on
a intérêt à ce que le système fonctionne
pour tout le monde et je crois que
partageons ce point de vue deuxième
élément vous dites tant que vous y êtes
si vous voulez crédibiliser ces
crédibiliser par la loi c'est
crédibilisé par désormais les règles qui
sont posées il faudra être crédibiliser
par le budget oui mais il faut aussi
crédibiliser le budget c'est à dire ne
pas faire croire on sait très bien tout
ça a été vu d'ailleurs avec les
organisations syndicales agricoles avec
les filières on a une trajectoire
on a une trajectoire triennale qui nous
amène dans le trienna la 600 millions
d'euros donc il y a c'est c'est posé sur
la table il me semble que budgétairement
c'est plutôt de bonne oeuvre de dire on
sait que cette année on est dans le
autour de 560 millions d'euros et qui ça
nous amène dans le Trianon si les
calculs sont bons si les trajectoires
sont bonnes mais après la réaction des
agriculteurs on la connaît ni moi et
donc on est bien dans 600 deuxième
élément pour être très précis pour le
coup parce que vous avez dit les mots du
président ont un sens et vous avez
raison de dire il a dit textuellement à
terre de gym c'est 600 qu'on mettra dans
le triennal et deux si ça débordait
jusqu'à 680 millions d'euros l'état
couvrira par ses moyens propres
l'assurance récolte donc il ne pouvait
pas être question de ce point de vue là
de toute façon d'aller à 680 millions
d'euros puisque c'est bien la couverture
de quelque chose qui serait plus
puissant il me semble qu'on a un travail
à faire collectivement notamment
me semble-t-il et je dirais un mot par
ailleurs de calamité agricole puisque
vous avez juste et ferez le sujet il me
semble que nous avons un travail à faire
maintenant c'est de conviction auprès
des agriculteurs
il y a un certain nombre de secteurs on
le sait vous le savez beaucoup mieux que
moi qui de l'arboriculture au prairies
ont besoin d'être convaincus de la
solidité du système donc ça c'est nous
tous et puis c'est évidemment les
organisations professionnelles agricoles
qui doivent pouvoir le porter sur le
terrain parce que je pense que c'est un
dispositif qui est solide deuxième
élément j'ai répondu sur la question des
calamités ça me permet de dire au
passage que comme vous le savez nous
avons accéléré ce qui n'avait jamais été
fait le processus de reconnaissance et
donc de versement des calamités
agricoles je le sais sur 12 départements
et pas l'ensemble des départements n'ont
pas été traités mais si on traite tous
les départements on aura le même
embouteillage je rappelle que calamité
agricole c'était plutôt versée en mars
avril les premières versements
interviendront début décembre pour les
12 départements concernés en partie ou
en totalité ça n'empêche pas que nous
continuons à faire le travail de terrain
pour faire en sorte qu'on regarde les
autres départements qui pourraient
rentrer dans la vie il y a en revanche
un sujet qui est un sujet effectivement
de débat c'est par quel voisin nous
c'est ça c'est sur le système prairial
c'est bien ça la question si j'ai bien
compris sous-jacente on reconnaît
la dégradation telle qui est plus
justifier de faire recours au système
assurantiel du jour ou de demain si je
peux dire au système des calamités
agricole moi je le dis très simplement
le système
di Airbus enfin le système satellitaire
c'est il fonctionne dans 90 à 95% des
cas donc je nous invite collectivement à
être prudent il ne faut pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau d'humain si vous me
permettez cette expression ça peut pas
être si on vous décide de faire des
enquêtes terrain sur toutes les prairies
de France les gens seront payés deux ans
plus tard donc on ne sait pas faire ça
et on ne peut pas faire ça en revanche
ce que j'ai dit c'est qu'on a d'ailleurs
on y va on va aller travailler avec les
secteurs concernés parce que c'est
vraiment le secteur préalable pour
regarder quand on a un désaccord entre
le satellite
et le terrain de regarder qu'est-ce
qu'on peut avoir comme ferme de
référence qui permettront de
crédibiliser définitivement mais j'ai
entendu certains qui décrédibilisaient
pas vous du tout
crédibiliser le système satellitaire le
système satellitaire il marche
il peut y avoir des pour des raisons
diverses et variées des choses qui ne
sont pas vues mais il me semble que
c'est un élément je disais ça quand
j'étais à Cournon c'est pas parce que la
météo se trompe de temps en temps qui
n'est pas utile de la regarder tous les
jours
ça marche globalement et il peut y avoir
des défauts et des failles dans le
système j'ai essayé de pas être aussi
long sur chaque point parce que madame
la Présidente je vais finir par être
non on essaie de s'auto réguler madame
la Présidente j'essaie de faire comme
tout le monde c'est dire si vous avez de
l'autorité sans être autoritaire non
mais c'est vrai de deuxième chose c'est
rien du cœur c'était vraiment pas
préparé deuxième chose que je voulais
dire sur le Théo de alors ça me
permettra de répondre il y a eu
il y a que vous monsieur Dupont je crois
qu'il m'avait interrogé sur le to d e
l'engagement du président des pays
c'était pour de faire en sorte que tous
les ans comme on a eu d'ailleurs il y a
des Marronniers comme on dit budgétaire
c'était le marronnier de est-ce qu'on
maintient les budgets des chambres
d'agriculture le marronnier c'est le cas
de le dire sur les affaires de bois et
de défibois et le tenait c'était tous
les ans une mise en sursis des choses le
président le dit dans le budget que nous
proposons d'abord on le réintègre donc
c'est une élément de crédibilisation
quand même dans le budget du ministère
de l'Agriculture
deuxième élément on a une perspective
qui a trois vous aurez des débats au
Sénat plus on donne de la prévisibilité
mieux c'est mais il me semble qu'à trois
ans déjà sur un dispositif comme
celui-là c'est intéressant il me semble
d'ailleurs moi je le dis personne à
titre de réflexion comme ça que je livre
il me semble que il faut qu'on regarde
ce qu'il peut y avoir comme nécessité je
pense en particulier à ce que vous dites
sur la compétitivité des filières pour
regarder dans quelle mesure il y aurait
des ajustements nécessaires pour aller
sur les filières qui pour le coup là
pour le pour lequel la main d'oeuvre est
un sujet absolument déterminant de
compétitivité donc on prolonge le to d e
tel qu'il est on le prolonge pour trois
ans il semble que c'est plutôt une
avancée même si elle vous paraît
insatisfaisante et je pense que ça va
plutôt dans le dans le bon sens police
sanitaire ça me permettra pour le coup
c'est là qu'il y avait deux
itérations de répondre aussi
à la sénatrice fera il me semble qu'il y
a plusieurs choses qu'il faut dire
d'abord on a des moyens complémentaires
90 ETP en plus des moyens qui sont
transférés de la DGCCRF
deuxième élément il faut se le dire il y
a quand même à faire converger des
cultures qui n'étaient pas tout à fait
des mêmes maisons
dit comme ça c'est
une façon gentille et diplomatique de le
dire on a besoin de faire converger les
cultures de maison et de gens qui
peut-être peuvent avoir des difficultés
à vivre le fait d'être placé sous la
tutelle du ministère de l'Agriculture
très bien donc on a besoin des c'est
tout le travail qu'on essaie de faire
j'ai dit qu'on prendrait de toute façon
les
contrôles continuent de s'exercer dans
les conditions qui dans lesquelles il
s'exerce aujourd'hui mais qu'il faudrait
prendre le temps ok le cas échéant pour
pas désorganiser le système parce que
l'idée c'est que en 2023 on produise
autant le contrôle qu'en 2022 et
qu'après l'idée c'est qu'on en puisse on
puisse en produire plus deuxième élément
que vous évoquez le hasard de la vie je
disais ça à votre président de ce matin
était fait que j'étais à Rungis ce matin
depuis ce matin et donc j'ai vu l'équipe
qui est quand même une équipe de plus
d'une trentaine de personnes il y a 36
personnes si je me souviens bien ce qui
m'a été dit ce matin de gens qui
effectivement sont les missions à la
fois de contrôle import et aussi de
soutien export parce qu'il y a dans les
deux sens à son utilité cette affaire
la question que vous posez moi je suis
assez ouvert à la question qu'on regarde
dans la déploiement des moyens on va
mettre en place les choses de regarder
et d'avoir une vigilance particulière
sur les endroits on a des besoins plus
spécifiques contenus de ce que sont les
risques
et compte tenu de ce que sont les
besoins la semaine c'est vous dites
départementales il me semble 20 sans
jouer sur les mots Rungis s'est dépassé
c'est dans les effectifs du département
du 94 mais je crois pouvoir vous dire
que les effectifs du 94 sont plus
importants que les effectifs du
Loir-et-Cher donc c'est pas tant la
question de me sentir départementale ou
pas national ou départemental c'est bien
que les gens soient Rungis donc ils sont
physiquement localisés ça me permettait
après qu'on regarde finement et cette
travail qu'on va faire dans les dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent
comment les répartit par rapport aux
besoins parce que vous avez raison dans
vos deux expressions je partage votre
sentiment le sujet c'est bien celui-là
c'est l'écloses miroir c'est les fraudes
c'est les risques sanitaires qui sont
afférents de produits qui viennent de
chez nous et puis ce de crédibiliser
nous-mêmes quand nous avons des actions
d'export vis-à-vis de nos partenaires à
l'extérieur de nos frontières voilà ce
que je voulais dire sur ce premier
élément deuxième élément pour compléter
on est en train de travailler sur la
manière dont se serait délégué les
contrôles alors il faut dire aussi
d'abord il faut dire une chose
je souffre pour sans doute comme
beaucoup d'entre vous du fait que il y a
des scandales sanitaires et par nature
c'est des scandales et par nature c'est
scandaleux encore plus qu'un des vies
humaines qui sont mises en cause mais
nous sommes le pays si ce n'est le plus
avancé ou le plus le meilleur en termes
de sécurité sanitaire des aliments enfin
l'accrédit-on pas collectivement l'idée
que nous en rabattrions et c'est pour ça
que c'est plutôt le sujet que vous
évoquez
c'est exactement ce que je disais le
sénateur
donc la question la police sanitaire
c'est de maintenir ce niveau d'exigence
mais ce niveau d'exigence c'est l'un ou
le meilleur du monde j'en parlais avec
des gens qui travaillent sur ces sujets
là aux États-Unis n'est pas du tout je
fais pas de grief on n'est pas du tout
dans le même registre en termes de
scandale sanitaire alors le risque zéro
c'est ce vers quoi il faut tendre mais
la question que vous posez plutôt celle
là je partage votre sentiment et donc
dans le travail que nous allons faire
puisque c'est une montée en charge
progressive je rappelle que la décision
a été déduite prise en avril semble-t-il
de la convergence il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on y travaille il me semble-t-il et
deuxième élément donc on travaille sur
qu'est-ce qui pourrait délégué on
travaille notamment sur de le délégué
des organismes qui ont déjà des
vocations sanitaires par exemple des
organismes de contrôle de végétaux
qui ont déjà une expertise et qui ont
une expertise reconnue d'intérêt général
si je peux dire et donc ça c'est un
élément qui me paraît me paraît
important à dire voilà sur la question
de la police
sanitaire sur la sur la sur
administration et proposition parce que
c'est une proposition de
désuranistration si vous permettez les
choses
alors les cas que vous évoquez il est
d'ailleurs déjà dans nos cas particulier
pour éclairer une multiplication des cas
particuliers peut faire parfois système
reconnaissons le donc
j'étais assez pour tout vous dire
arrivant à ce poste et Pharrell du fait
que l'oubli de cochage d'une case puisse
avoir des conséquences il y a pas de
mauvaise intentions je le dis parce
qu'il faut défendre aussi les
administrations de la part des
administrations le système tel qu'il a
été conçu dans la pacte qui se termine
il ne permet pas le droit à l'erreur et
donc il produit ça
parce qu'après c'est des mécanismes qui
sont des mécanismes de contrôle je le
regrette absolument comme vous c'est
pour ça que j'ai moi-même présidé la
réunion qui s'est tenue et qui se tient
pour la mise parce que la PAC a été
décidé je pense qu'elle est plutôt de
bonne facture la mise en œuvre de la
pacte pour faire pour éviter les écueils
qu'on a connu dans la précédente
programmation au début et incapacité à
payer dans les délais c'est un élément
très important et j'attache une
importance particulière ça va de ce
point de vue là dans votre sens à la
question de d'un réel doit à l'erreur et
donc en particulier sur les sujets que
vous évoquez précisément la question de
dire
on note un problème dans votre
déclaration on vous le signale vous
pouvez corriger vous pouvez modifier
dans une durée qui est beaucoup plus
longue
ça ça me paraît de nature à répondre non
pas à la situation précise mais en tout
cas essayer de résoudre alors on regarde
les situations précises croyez bien
qu'on essaie de le faire dans les
services mais ça permet de répondre à la
question que vous sollicitez c'est qu'il
y a un peu de bienveillance parce que
c'est ça le droit à l'erreur c'est qu'on
peut se tromper de cocher une case on
peut oublier ça nous est d'ailleurs tous
arrivé sans conséquence de paiement de
la Pâque mais ça nous est tous arrivé
dans une déclaration d'impôts de pouvoir
le droit de recommencer sa déclaration
donc ça c'est un élément j'en viens à
votre proposition alors pardon de vous
le dire sans être trop long mais il y a
des registres de nature différentes
c'est vrai que parfois le la
surperposition des choses sont des
superpositions qui peuvent créer de la
dépense ou ça souvent été documenté
moi-même et restant conseiller municipal
et conseiller communautaire j'ai souvent
c'est pas très nouveau pour tout vous
dire j'ai peur que ça fasse au moins 27
ans que je le dise que la superposition
des choses crée parfois des surcoûts
c'est pas tout à fait le même nature
égalive c'est une intention personne
n'est pénalisée parce qu'il n'atteint
pas gallima non non
personne n'est vraiment pénalisé c'est
pour l'instant c'est pas
bon alors après vous dites d'autres
sujets c'est les coûts inflationnistes
là et de la loi AGEC moi il me semble
qu'après une fois qu'on le faut qu'on
assume le sujet c'est plutôt qu'on se
pose la question pardon je dis aussi
franchement que ça quand on vote des
textes de regarder les conséquences
qu'on peut avoir et parfois c'est tout
le monde paraît des meilleurs intentions
tout le monde est d'accord pour sortir
des emballages plastiques et puis après
la traduction c'est pas la même j'essaie
de ne pas opposer quand même des
nécessités quand même qu'on a pour
orienter des choses
personne n'a envie qu'on continue à
avoir une une logique d'emballage
plastique telle qu'elle est sur le donc
il faut bien un moment qu'on vote des
dispositions législatives après la
question et c'est peut-être une des voix
qu'il faut avoir c'est le moment de la
transition c'est à dire que je pense que
la durée de transition est un sujet
qu'il faut avoir avant nous c'est tout
le sujet pour moi en agriculture de la
planification de leur conseil la
trajectoire si ça doit être un an c'est
un an si ça doit être cinq ans c'est 5
ans et si ça doit être dix ans c'est 10
ans ça crédibilise la démarche et ça
permet aux opérateurs aux acteurs aux
acteurs collectivités locales ne
semble-t-il de pouvoir s'adapter
j'en viens à Madame Ferrat j'ai répondu
sur la sur la question sur la question
de la
de des contrôles sécurité sanitaires sur
les questions du des moyens dédiés aux
mal-être agricoles c'est un sujet dont
nous sommes saisis grâce à la
sollicitation beaucoup d'entre vous au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale
d'abord je le dis mais c'est pas ici que
je devrais le dire mais je le dis quand
même puisque c'est une partie du
mal-être agricole il est la situation
financière
il est le sentiment d'être dans une
impasse il est le regard que disent les
choses que disent des gens
à longueur de journaux et de média
et donc nous avons collectivement en
tout cas moi j'essaie de prendre ma part
et c'est pas c'est pas une injonction
contre vous mais collectivement il faut
qu'on soit extrêmement vigilant quand
vous avez des gens qui passent leur
temps à dire aux gens vous avez peur qui
sont pollueurs qui sont dans une impasse
que il faut que telle filière
disparaisse que par nature on ferait ça
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
construit le mal-être psychologique des
agriculteurs et donc il faut qu'on lutte
absolument collectivement contre ça et
vous m'avez trouvé et vous me trouverez
assez ferme sur les prix parce que je
pense que c'est le minimum qu'on doit
aux agriculteurs quand on a parfois des
difficultés à résoudre les deux les deux
items je réponds précisément à votre
question
c'est près de 12 millions d'euros par an
un budget supplémentaire sur les
dispositifs d'intervention plus de 12
millions de plus
alors je vais vous les donner mais on
voulait donnera dans des tableaux que je
n'ai pas sous les yeux mais
je vais essayer de vous le dire en tout
cas à l'oral mais on vous les on voulait
je propose que mes équipes voulaient
fassent passer plus 3,5 millions pour le
dispositif area plus 1,4 pour le
dispositif aide au répit qui est de
l'accompagnement que fait la MSA plus
2,3 millions pour les aides financières
de la MSA à destination des entreprises
pour l'amélioration des conditions de
travail parfois c'est un sujet pour des
agriculteurs plus 1,6 millions pour le
débranchement durant du crédit pour
remplacement
et plus j'y retour alors je pense que
nous devons faire encore plus la
promotion des
de la du service de remplacement ça
n'est pas dans la culture du monde
agricole que de se dire j'ai besoin de
répit
et donc il faut qu'on essaie de
porter pour une charge qu'on leur fait
porter inconscient enfin je sais pas je
sais pas comment vous exprimer ça
autrement et de leur dire que on a le
droit au pire on a le droit aux vacances
on a le droit d'avoir envie de prendre
deux jours c'est pas c'est pas une
faiblesse et donc c'est il faut aussi
qu'on a sur la promotion et puis 3,1
millions d'euros de prestations
remise d'un dus pour précarité etc de
prestations de la MSA ça c'est les
éléments budgétaires pour le déploiement
du plan de prévention
il y a une cinquantaine de départements
dans lequel il est correctement pour
être juste avec vous 50 départements
dans lequel il est correctement déployé
j'ai demandé j'ai fait j'ai tenu une
réunion une quinzaine de jours pour dire
que maintenant il fallait que ça finisse
de se déployer dans l'ensemble des
départements
c'est une question moyen mais c'est une
question aussi de de mise en réseau
d'acteurs les champs de l'agriculture la
MSA parfois les collectivités locales
qui peuvent avoir un regard et pour
avoir le je pense en particulier au
département et donc c'est aussi ça sur
lequel il faut que nous puissions jouer
pardon sur ces affaires là donc on va
assouplir
on avait des engagements dans la feuille
de route l'assouplissement de la
procédure d'aide à la relance des
exploitations agricoles la réa donc un
octroie du RSA en urgence aux
agriculteurs j'avais un débat l'autre
jour en disant les agriculteurs ne
demandent pas le RSA mais je sais bien
qu'il ne demande pas le RSA mais dans
une urgence qui est l'urgence de vivre
le médecin c'est pas une
c'est pas pour faire du RSA c'est juste
que dans des situations d'extrême
précarité c'est une voix et un moyen là
aussi qu'il faut qu'il faut assumer
comme tel pour permettre à une chute
soudaine des revenus et puis il y a
évidemment les éléments alors ça c'est
pas ceux qui sont actifs mais c'est les
éléments des lois dit Chassaigne 1 et 2
d'ailleurs il s'appelle Chassaigne 1 et
2 sur la revalorisation des retraites
agricoles il y a des progrès qui peuvent
être faits un élargir enfin s'assurer
que le dispositif est bien couvert dans
l'ensemble des départements et puis de
faire vivre en permanence et moi à
chaque fois que je me déplace je demande
au préfet comment ça se passe dans quel
situation on est quels sont les
difficultés que vous rencontrez voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire sur les moyens
sur la philosophie il faut que nous
ayons pour essayer d'avancer sur cette
sur cette question alors j'ai perdu ma
feuille donc je n'ai pas la suite si
vous m'avez vous m'avez évoqué pardon
j'ai oublié je voulais pas ne pas
aborder cette question du sujet qui a eu
des contrôles et en particulier d'un
contrôle
dans lequel à l'issue à la à l'issue ou
dans la foulée de ce contrôle on assiste
on a eu malheureusement le suicide
agriculteur j'ai demandé j'ai dit
déjanté j'ai demandé à ce qu'on dit des
gens une enquête administrative pour
savoir dans quelle mesure et dans quel
de quelle manière s'était passé le
contrôle alors j'essaie de vous dire les
choses avec la pondération que beaucoup
me connaissent ici il faut qu'on assume
il faut qu'on assume la nécessité de
contrôle
on a besoin de faire des contrôles il
faut qu'on assume aussi attends je
il faut qu'on a je veux pas ne pas je
peux pas ne pas le dire parce que c'est
au fond ce que je pense il faut qu'on
assume aussi le fait qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver des voies et moyens
pour que la confiance
se renforce sur la question des
contrôles il y a plusieurs choses un la
multiplication des contrôles ça rejoint
un peu ce que vous dites c'est-à-dire
que parfois vous avez un contrôle sursis
un contrôle sur ça et donc il faut quand
même qu'on essaie de regarder deux qu'on
essaie d'avoir des contrôles qui soient
des contrôles qui ne portent pas d'abord
la charge
et qui sait de démontrer que la parole
de contradictoire puisse être entendu
mais vous m'entendrez pas comme ministre
de la même communiste de l'agriculture
ce serait une facilité dire il faut il
faut rabattre et mettre en cause des
agents il a la plupart des agents de
l'OV ils font leur travail comme la
plupart des gens qui font des contrôles
c'est jamais très amusant de faire un
contrôle mais après la question
d'essayer de retrouver de la confiance
dans ses affaires là peut-être que
quelqu'un parle de ça mais tout à
l'heure mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
budget mais les questions de prédation
c'est une question de confiance par
exemple sur le dénombrement
et donc on a besoin de retrouver la
confiance de la confiance des agents et
de la confiance des agriculteurs
vis-à-vis du contrôleur là il y a un
travail qui est à faire me semble-t-il
sur le cas particulier c'est un cas
douloureux d'abord par nature et je
pense à sa famille et est-ce qu'il a
vécu les
sujets
qui amène au suicide c'est suffisamment
complexe pour pas m'aventurer sur les
choses ça n'empêche que ça pose des
questions sur la manière dont ils
peuvent se dérouler les contrôles et le
sentiment qui peut être vécu peu importe
qu'il soit tort ou à raison
oui mais je dis attention mais vous
m'entendez pas dans mon propos
daigner le sujet je dis il faut qu'on y
travaille c'est à dire que la question
c'est de d'arriver à faire dialoguer
tout le monde pour dire voilà les
conditions dans lesquelles doivent se
passer les choses voilà comment éviter
superpositions de contrôle et voilà
comment on met pas les gens les acculent
pas avec le sentiment d'une espèce de
culpabilité
il y a beaucoup de cas où c'est parce
que alors je le dis d'ailleurs au
passage parce que on ne connaît pas bien
la réglementation alors une naissance
ignorer la loi mais reconnaissons
sinon c'est Monsieur c'est Monsieur
Duplan qui va le dire après on remonte
reconnaissons que la loi est complexe
j'ai demandé d'ailleurs dans le travail
que j'ai j'ai effectué avec le directeur
de l'OSB est vraiment je crois qu'il
veut s'engager avec ses agents là-dessus
c'est la modification de la PAC il y a
de nouvelles règles
et donc il faut qu'on ait une période au
moment on va mettre en oeuvre la plaque
on regarde ça avec qui est la capacité
de de d'appréhender et de
sa culture et si vous permettez cette
question aux nouveaux dispositif de la
PAC il y a des écorigimes il y a des
choses nouvelles il y a la question du
calcul des enfin bref je vais pas faire
le détail de la fac devant vous mais là
on a besoin quand même qu'on se donne
des règles pour que le 2 janvier on
commence par voilà ça n'empêche pas
qu'il faut des contrôles c'est une
question d'ailleurs de crédibilité sinon
de crédibilité dans les dispositifs
d'aide tout le monde fait des contrôles
sur les aides il me semble que c'est un
élément important pardon je voulais le
dire parce que c'est comme vous l'aviez
évoqué c'était un sujet qui dernier
alors dernier point alors sur les
crédits vétérinaires la dotation des
stages n'a pas diminué mais le nombre
d'étudiants
à augmenter en fait donc c'est plutôt
comme ça que l'explication se fait
oui mais comment
oui ça fera partie de notre débats je
réponds à votre
imagine qu'en séance par ailleurs on a
un sujet plus lourd et compris de
mal-être aussi chez les vétérinaires
troisièmement on a un sujet on rencontre
dans le monde vétérinaire ce qu'on
rencontre dans le monde médical
on a un besoin je suis en train de
travailler avec les professionnels de
savoir de nouveaux mécanismes qui se
montent en terme vétérinaire de clinique
de grande ampleur qui viennent
privilégier plutôt
la médecine
vétérinaire canine comme on dit
oui donc oui mais ça c'est pas la
question c'est pas la seulement la
question du tutorat c'est la question
des mécanismes il y a il y a un décret
qui est en attente qui peut régler un
certain nombre de problèmes et de
questions sur ce sujet-là donc c'est la
panoplie des sujets mais nous en
reparlerons évidemment sur le sur le
sujet sur le sujet budgétaire
crise influence ça vire je ne sais plus
quel était la question
comment
oui alors le vaccin alors
on va je disais ça et c'est vraiment pas
pour plaisanter les éleveurs sont en
train de vivre ce qu'on a pu vivre dans
une autre crise sanitaire qui était la
crise pour ce qui était des
restaurateurs ou d'autres c'est
confinement des confinements confinement
des confinements bon je vois très bien
la situation de détresse dans laquelle
ils sont simplement aujourd'hui moi
j'essaie de prendre mes décisions sous
le sous le regard des scientifiques en
particulier de ce que dit lances de ce
que dit la DGL et ils nous disent
aujourd'hui que je vais venir sur le
vaccin que les dispositions qu'on a sont
de nature à essayer de freiner cette
influenza qui est très particulière en
plus cette année puisque elle est restée
sur le territoire national en faune
sauvage et qu'elle repart en partie de
la faune sauvage du territoire national
et elle vient être renforcée en ce
moment pas le phénomène migratoire
et donc c'est les migrations de faune
sauvage sont en train de venir on est à
49 cas aujourd'hui on a des points de
très grande vigilance
parce que ça aussi c'est une atypicité
2021-2022 sur en Région Pays Loire et
Bretagne parce qu'en plus c'est la
région des accouvoirs c'est la région où
on produit et donc ce qui se passe on
peut les lois et Bretagne c'est ce qui
va se passer dans le Sud-Ouest c'est ce
qui s'est d'ailleurs passé
et donc on va on va être obligé de
graduer les mesures je les dis ce matin
sur Public Sénat d'ailleurs je crois en
disant on est en train de regarder
comment évolue l'influenza pour regarder
il faut pas avoir des mesures d'un
niveau supérieur personne ne prend
plaisir à ça deuxième élément le vaccin
on est dans on va assez vite quand même
puisque autorisation au mois de juin
lors d'un Conseil européen le
immédiatement le process
d'expérimentation s'est lancé
3 ou 4 pays dont la France qui lancent
expérimentation les premiers éléments
mais nous prenons-le avec la prudence
les premiers éléments sont plutôt
encourageants le résultat on aura les
résultats en décembre décembre janvier
ce qui nous permettra en l'espère
d'avoir un plan de vaccination parce
qu'il faut avoir une stratégie vaccinale
quels sont les volailles quels sont le
type de d'animaux qu'on vaccinant
priorité et deuxième élément sur lequel
il faut qu'on travaille c'est les
éléments qui ne viennent pas non plus
freiner l'export à l'extérieur des
frontières Union européenne c'est une
partie de notre filière volaille à
l'export
donc c'est
qualification du vaccin c'est ça c'est
mon expert pour descendre c'est ce qu'on
nous dit deuxième élément
c'est la capacité en même temps de
négocier et de regarder au niveau
européen comment avec les pays tiers on
se met bien d'accord sur les modalités
d'export peut-être que ça peut faire
évoluer notre stratégie vaccinale et
puis stratégie vaccinale on va déployer
j'ai espoir alors je veux jamais donner
trop d'espoir qu'on a passé mais j'ai
espoir quand même que
passer cet épisode d'influence de la
Vierge on puisse avoir au travers du
vaccin un certain nombre de solutions
mais nous sommes dans la crise donc
c'est je peux pas dire que j'ai résolu
là le sujet l'influence avia mais
j'aurais vraiment saluer le travail qui
est fait en plus je le dis franchement
avec les organisations professionnelles
de ces sujets là sur ces filières là qui
sont faits dans les départements parce
que
dans beaucoup de départements les ddspp
les DDT sont mobilisés y compris parfois
le jour et nuit compris pendant les
périodes de fêtes parce que il y a un
cas il faut faire les zones de
protection parce qu'il faut faire les
caressages parce qu'il faut s'organiser
franchement la continuité la solidarité
qui s'est d'exercer entre les
collectivités qui sont pas parfois
revenus en soutien les services de
l'État en territoire qui ont été H24
parfois et les filières est assez
remarquable donc mais je vois très bien
le sentiment que il y a une forme de
désespérance et pour certains éleveurs
de dire en sortira jamais d'où les
mesures d'accompagnement mais je reviens
pas vous les connaissez donc je reviens
pas là-dessus j'en finis sur la question
des deux questions
comment ah oui mais
je suis vraiment trop long mais enfin
c'est quand même des sujets
coupures d'électricité oui c'est alors
on a faut dire une chose oui
l'agroalimentaire la continuité la
chaîne alimentaire on peut pas se faire
de grief entre nous là-dessus c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait sur la covid
est-ce que c'est simple non parce que
quand vous êtes dans des coupures
électriques dans des zones où vous avez
une entreprise en bout de la ligne et
que vous avez un circuit c'est pas
simple donc ça ça nécessite un travail
fin on va on réunit depuis plusieurs
semaines
chaque semaine sous l'autorité de
Matignon et de ministère de l'intérieur
comme ça a été fait d'ailleurs sur covid
une cellule qui va regarder cas par cas
d'appartement par département quels sont
les problèmes qui se posent quels sont
dans les prioritaires de l'agriculture
et l'agroalimentation les Ultra
prioritaires enfin bref vous voyez bien
comment se fait ce genre de d'exercice
de priorité mais évidemment je vous
reconfle ce que j'ai dit y compris
ailleurs mais une fois qu'on l'a dit
c'est pas aussi simple que cela a
déployer parce que ça dépend de l'appel
d'énergie ça dépend du réseau comment il
est constitué à l'endroit où il y a
entreprise et donc c'est ça c'est
maintenant on essaie de regarder avec
les préfets départements de départ
département les endroits on peut avoir
un problème
ne remettant pas en cause la philosophie
que je développe que je devais demander
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
c'est pas simplement on a rien sur ces
il suffit pas de le dire et après il
faut essayer de voir par capillarité
comment ça se passe concrètement et
quels sont les conséquences pour
certains d'une j'étais dans votre
département à visiter une usine de
transformation de pommes de terre pour
faire des frites pour faire pour dire un
mot plus simple on connaît tous les
conséquences pour eux sont d'une nature
qui ne sont pas tout à fait les mêmes
que pour une filière laitière et pour au
passage dire qu'il y a un certain nombre
d’ailleurs d'opérateurs qui ont fait je
pense à la filière betterave qui ont
fait un gros effort pour faire les
appels d'énergie là et pour avoir un
cycle plus court pour avoir moins besoin
de la plaie de l'énergie au moment où il
y a le plus de risques et ce travail qui
a été fait par un certain nombre de
piliers de filières est à saluer c'est
un travail de responsabilité
donc c'est pas toujours comment
je finis sur deux ou trois sujets qui
ont été évoqués sur la filière alors je
partage mais on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en reparler mais ce que
vous dites sur la nécessité de repenser
les modes de gestion repenser la forêt
repenser la mixité je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous mais il y a des gens
à qui il va falloir expliquer qu'on va
pas planter des lettres
dans des territoires qui alors que le
être est en voie de disparition sur le
territoire français donc la mixité va
falloir se mettre d'accord ce où elle
est possible parce que la réalité qui va
s'imposer à nous c'est le climat et le
sol
quand même faut se le dire parce que
je vais pas faire mes heures de ma
mais parfois il y a des émissions il y a
des gens qui vous expliquent des choses
qui sont un peu théoriques
je sais pas ce que vous avez dit vous
non parce que je vous réponds le prenez
pas pour une attaque personnelle mais
c'est c'est assez simple de dire il y a
qu'à faucon sur ces sujets là je rejoins
ce que vous avez dit on a besoin de
renforcer les moyens de la recherche
parce qu'on a des sujets sur lesquels
sans doute depuis trop longtemps on n'a
pas mis assez de moyens pour savoir non
pas seulement documenter ce que va être
ce que vont être les effets du
dérèglement climatique mais quels sont
les bonnes essences aux bonnes endroits
comment on assure parfois de la mixité
comment on assure on a perdu en 15 ans
je crois de la moitié de notre capacité
de stockage carbone en forêt
et donc faut qu'on assume aussi que des
modalités et de gestion et de
replantation permettent de reconquérir
cette capacité de stockage carbone je
sais aussi les attentes de la société
donc il faut qu'on arrive à trouver un
point d'équilibre qui soit pas
simplement la caricature ce que je vois
très bien que le résineux va devenir la
victime explicatoire de la forêt comme
le maïs et la victime exploitatoire des
sujets d'eau vous voyez c'est pas ce que
vous faites mais je réponds quand même à
cette question en disant qu'il va
falloir qu'on essaie de poser
tranquillement les choses et de trouver
des solutions territoire par territoire
et donc on a besoin de documenter sur la
recherche ça me permet de dire deux
choses sur l'ONF par nature d'abord il y
a une nouvelle directrice comme l'a dit
votre présidente par nature le contrat
onef il était basé sur une trajectoire y
compris une trajectoire de moyens
humains par nature ça nécessite me
semble-t-il qu'on en discute
ne faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit
ça mérite qu'on leur dit vous me
demandez d'être comme ça audacieux en
commission
vous me la reposerez en séance mais
évidemment c'est le contrat d'objectif
c'est un contrat d'objectif et de moyens
dès lors qu'on dit que sur les moyens on
a des évolutions nouvelles alors après
moi je partage un peu alors je veux pas
travailler à la pensée de la présidente
la question des moyens n'est pas la
seule question la question c'est les
objectifs
oui non non parce qu'il faut il faut
qu'on dise quels sont les moyens sur
lequel ça me permet de répondre une
partie des 20 millions d'euros qui vont
être qui vont vous être proposés dans le
budget c'est des moyens qui sont pour du
matériel et c'est des moyens pour
permettre à l'ONU parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait trop souvent non content et
c'est une trajectoire très longue chacun
porte sa part mais là la trajectoire est
assez longue sur l'ONF qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait c'est que ce content d'avoir fait
ça on lui a demandé des missions
supplémentaires or
elle a des missions supplémentaires et
va avoir des missions plus importantes
en particulier sur l'incendie donc ça
vise à couvrir les besoins qu'on va lui
demander sur la question de la
prévention des incendies pour aller dans
votre sens et des questions matérielles
et par ailleurs globalement il faut
qu'on se pose des questions que vous
êtes posé sur l'affaire des des
filières forestières sur le casse d'art
alors
j'ai dit tout à l'heure la chose
suivante je sais la question du plafond
ça c'est l'un des derniers marronniers
pardon l'expression ça n'est pas
péjoratif chez moi mais ça fait
longtemps que le casse d'art est une
question c'est une taxe affecté ça pose
toujours des questions c'est des sujets
c'est des sujets budgétaires
ce que j'ai dit c'est qu'on est bien
dans le plafond et on renouvelle cette
question du plafond ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure c'est que les crédits qui ont
été en surplus cette année ils seront
bien redéployés sur 2023 pour déployer
des programmes de recherche parce qu'on
a besoin de recherche j'ajoute les
attire votre attention sur le fait qu'on
a besoin aussi ça me permet de répondre
à une question de la présidente de
mobiliser les crédits on va en mobiliser
avec ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau qui
travaille activement le sujet sur les
questions de la forêt au travers de
programme qu'on va soutenir qu'on va
essayer de soutenir au travers de France
c'est à dire qu'il y a pas que le casse
d'art France 2030 c'est des moyens qui
sont qui peuvent être colossaux c'est
2,9 milliards d'euros forêt transition
agricole transition alimentaire qu'on
peut développer le plan protéines ce
qu'on a fait l'autre jour sur sur les
levures qu'on a été voir avec on était
inauguré si je peux dire avec avec
Sylvie Retailleau tout ça c'est des
moyens de recherche encore plus
puissants quelle case d'art mais ça
n'éduque pas la question mais je veux
dire simplement que pour 2023 les
reliquats seront bien remis dans le
casse
j'ai bien compris j'ai bien compris mais
c'est tout le sujet des taxes affectés
parce qu'après
oui très bien mais essayons oui mais là
je vous dis que ça fêté va permettre de
faire ça il me semble que c'est un
élément important et puis dernier point
la question du modèle agricole c'est la
question qui est devant nous ça me
permet de répondre aussi à la question
de la présidente mais je crois que j'ai
commencé à le faire sur la loi
d'orientation la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est la loi d'orientation et d'un
visa renouvellement des générations
c'est une loi qui doit poser aussi les
principes de quel est le modèle alors
j'ai du mal à dire le modèle
moi le bon modèle c'est le modèle qui va
permettre à des agriculteurs de résoudre
les problèmes alors ça c'est pas
forcément cette loi là mais la
rémunération l'adaptation changement
climatique la nature des filières et ben
un modèle parce que
pardon se manithéisme qu'on a parfois
vous l'avez pas eu mais je veux dire il
y a pas un modèle de d'agriculture il y
a des modèles qui sont sur des petites
structures il y en a qui nécessiteront
des moyens capitalistiques qui sont plus
importants et qui va falloir accompagner
enfin bref mais évidemment c'est la
question qu'il faut se poser la question
du modèle un modèle qui dont on peut se
dire que dans 30 ou 40 ans il tient
encore on peut penser c'est ça le beau
le mot modèle ou les bons modèles qu'il
faut déployer pardon madame la
Présidente mais je crois que j'ai
répondu à tout
c'était quoi votre dernière question
sur les filières élevage et chambre
froide est-ce qu'il y aura des aides à
priori plutôt qu'à posteriori d'ailleurs
je sais pas ce que vous voulez dire dans
les aides à priori parce qu'à un moment
il va falloir
a priori a postérieuse je sais ce que ça
veut dire
je me suis levé tôt mais j'ai encore un
petit peu de mais je sais pas si on peut
en débat ici mais non mais alors il y a
deux choses à faire alors je vais vous
dire il y a deux choses à faire la
première chose vous avez complètement
raison la première chose
on va être sur une aide guichet mais la
première chose qu'on a à dire c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de d'imprévisibilité
pour les acteurs ils ont besoin de
savoir que de quel dispositif et à quel
dispositif on va pouvoir émarger c'est
plutôt le ce qu'on appelle le dispositif
guichet auquel vous faites référence
vont pouvoir émerger pour moi c'est une
guichet et donc c'est plutôt à faire on
va travailler à faire en sorte que le
dispositif il puisse dire vous rentrez
ou pas dans les clous après est-ce qu'on
puisse on peut débloquer vous savez que
c'est compliqué quand vous commencez à
débloquer c'est ça dépend si c'est 8
principes ou paiement de principe
je suis d'accord mais moi je voulais
juste vous comprenez bien là ce que peut
avoir aujourd'hui il y a un produit mais
je comprends
est-ce qu'il met en route et ce qui
m'aide des bandes de poulet dans son
poulailler ça veut dire qu'il enclenche
le gaz l'électricité etc et qu'il aura
obligatoirement des factures de gaz et
d'électricité très élevé à cause de
l'augmentation d'énergie et on va lui
demander de devoir constater son déficit
avant de pouvoir l'aider non non c'est
le troisième je parle du troisième
guichet pour celui-là qu'on est encore
en train de travailler parce qu'on a
besoin et je le dis au parlementaire que
vous êtes comme on l'a fait sur covid on
voit bien que parfois il est trop dans
la raquette donc il faut que j'assume
que il faut il faut deuxième élément ça
va être géré par la DG fibre qui a été
très efficace d'ailleurs dans la crise
covid donc c'est sur production de
facture que le versement donc c'est
plutôt une forme d'automaticité qui est
gérée c'est plutôt excenté qu'expose
tout a priori qui a postériori
très bien c'est l'épée de la monnaie
je crois que c'est l'épée de Damoclès
sur l'éligibilité à postérieur oui oui
c'est ça voilà c'est ça j'ai bien
compris
ah non non c'est pas le sujet non non
très bien je pense que d'ici pardon
d'ici le débat que nous aurons en séance
on aura des éléments plus qui vous perd
parce que là on aura le guichet qui sera
ouvert et on aura les modalités très
bien merci avant de vous laisser la
parole je vais laisser la parole à
Vincent Segoin qui est le rapporteur
spécial la commission des finances
peut-être nous dire un mot sur ce le
point de vue de la commission des
finances
merci madame la Présidente beaucoup de
choses ont été dit Monsieur le Ministre
ravi de vous entendre
donc nous on a on a un paramètre au
niveau de la commission des finances on
a vu que les budgets en augmentation que
l'assurance récolte c'était un sujet sur
lequel vous avez répondu et par des
budgets certes qui sont pas au niveau
que mais mais en espérant que l'adhésion
soit au rendez-vous
je voulais surtout revenir sur sur le la
balance commerciale
on en parle beaucoup on en parle au
niveau de l'économie dans l'ensemble de
l'économie et c'est vrai que la balance
commerciale de l'agriculture était
excédentaire aujourd'hui elle est portée
uniquement par les vins et les
spiritueux
ce qui veut dire qu'on a fait on a perdu
du marché dans toute les autres
productions
alors on le voit bien quand on utilise
ça de plus près on s'aperçoit que la
ferme France a perdu de la compétitivité
elle a un poids d'énorme qui pèse elle a
un coût du travail qui est élevé alors
certes on met des mes collègues en ont
parfaitement parlé on met des procédures
mais qui sont pas pérennes alors c'est
quand même relativement compliqué pour
un jeune quand il s'installe de faire un
prévisionnel à trois ans ou à 5 ans et
on voit bien dans le taux de
remplacement que c'est que que on n'a
pas l'objectif atteint et que on a un
nombre d'exploitations qui diminue donc
je revenais on a des normes
franco-françaises des normes de
surtransposition on devait y mettre fin
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on est mis fin
on a de plus en plus l'impression et mes
collègues se sont très bien exprimés sur
le sujet que l'administration elle elle
condamne plus l'entreprise française que
par ces normes que les produits intrants
vous avez dit que vous étiez sensible et
que vous allez mettre les moyens en face
pour que les normes soient respectées
dans les que la clause miroir soit soit
respectée alors une question à ce sujet
là ça veut dire que les contrats de
libre-échange n'auront plus d'avenir ils
vont s'arrêter puisque le l'objectif des
contrats de libre-échange c'est
justement de pas de ne plus faire de
contrôle
voilà enfin il y a tout un ensemble de
questions qui est posée par le la
commission des finances sur l'ensemble
de ces sujets on a on est vraiment
inquiet par cette perte de compétitivité
de la ferme France et on voulait vous
entendre savoir comment vous allez entre
l'écologie
entre le pouvoir d'achat des Français et
les orientations et le développement de
l'économie agricole vous alliez
budgétisé et gérer des choses pour
l'avenir merci
beaucoup je pense qu'on va commencer la
série de questions vraiment je vous
demanderai cher collègues au-delà de ce
que je vous ai écrit de pas reposer des
questions que ont été déjà posées voilà
et qui nous ferait à tous perdre du
temps Daniel Laurent monsieur le
Président du Groupe 20 sera suivi de
Rémi Cardon madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre justement en amont
de la visite du président de la
République aux États-Unis début décembre
visant à souligner les liens économiques
forts entre de nos deux nations nous
avons souhaité au nom de la commission
des affaires économiques et du groupe
vignevin donc au signé avec Sophie
primat un courrier pour attirer
l'attention du Président de la
République sur le règlement définitif du
contentieux commercial aéronautique
qui subit plein fou que subit plein
fouet la filière viticole nous comptons
sur vous monsieur le ministre pour nous
soutenir et intervenir auprès du
président de la République parce que
pour que ce contentieux s'arrête parce
qu'il est en suspens il n'est pas arrêté
donc c'est dangereux pour la filière qui
est excédentaire vous avez entendu tout
à l'heure dans mon copain à Vincent
deuxième point les dégustations
gratuites de vins sont exonérées
d'assise en l'absence de transaction
commerciale cette tradition est remise
en cause selon l'administration sous la
représente entre 400 et 600.000 euros de
droits exonérés quelle réponse
pouvez-vous apporter aux vignerons
deuxième question la loi pour assurer la
régulation de l'accès aux frontières
agricole au travers des structures
sociétaires est entrée en vigueur or
elle est inapplicable en raison de la
non publication des décrets merci c'est
urgent troisième question dans les zones
insulaires atlantiques des projets de
transformation et commercialisation de
produits agricoles sont bloqués en
raison de la loi littorale ce qui
inquiète les agriculteurs inscrits dans
le maintien des activités agricoles il
faut que ces activités se considérées
dans le prolongement de l'acte de
production
j'espère que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
quatrième quatrième question
sur le projet de la belle bio pour le
sel les producteurs de sel marin de
l'Atlantique s'interroge les
négociations n'avancent pas et font
apparaître des positions antagonistes de
plusieurs pays de l'Union européenne les
petits producteurs attendent des
réponses concrètes je ne peux me de
votre éponge écrite du 3 novembre à une
question écrite qui n'apporte aucun
élément tangible donc merci de me faire
une réponse concrète et puis je
terminerai juste en évoquant ce qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure concernant les
vétérinaires puisque j'ai été interpellé
moi aussi dans ma région par le
président des vétérinaires le maillage
sanitaire est en péril vous parliez tout
à l'heure de problème ça a répondu le
maillage sanitaire est en péril donc et
surtout dans la ruralité merci Daniel la
parole est à Rémi Cardon et cette
fois-ci j'enclenche mon chronomètre
monsieur le ministre
habitant à proximité des hortillages
dans la Somme je vais faire un focus sur
les petites structures bio alternatives
et urbaines qui sont en tout cas sont
une manière de mettre un peu d'urbanité
dans le monde agricole et de remettre au
goût du jour des pratiques culturales et
de favoriser les connexions entre le
monde rural et le le monde urbain elle
contribue à la sécurité alimentaire à la
création des liens sociaux et à la lutte
contre le changement climatique les
impacts économiques et environnementaux
sont indéniblesment positifs
malheureusement ces dispositifs d'aide
et de soutien sont encore trop liés à la
surface exploitée donc ma question est
la suivante avec ce PLF que comptez-vous
faire pour que les nouvelles formes
d'agriculture ne soient pas qu'une
variable d'ajustement dans la prise mais
au contraire un levier de résilience des
petites des villes et de la transition
écologique autrement dit est-ce que vous
allez déconfiner un plan résilience sur
des petites structures alternatives bio
je prends le mot que vous avez employé
tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame la
présidente du groupe forêt du groupe
d'études forêts Anne-Catherine Loisier
puis ensuite à Fabien gay merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur ministre alors
d'abord pour compléter les propos de mon
collègue Jean-Claude Tissot avec
lesquels je suis en parfaite accord
notamment sur la nécessité de revoir le
contrat d'objectif onfa donc dans ce
proche de finance monsieur le ministre
donc le gouvernement actes sa décision
de revenir en fait sur les suppressions
de postes à l'ONF
et donc il en par contre d'après ce que
j'ai compris non financer rêve 60 et il
en laisserait 20 à la charge de l'ONF
donc si vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi puisque malheureusement on le
sait sauf adores exceptions jamais le
budget de l'ONF c'est-à-dire les
recettes issues des ventes n'ont permis
d'atteindre un équilibre budgétaire donc
comment vont-ils financer ces 20 postes
sauf à faire des restrictions par
ailleurs et puis qu'en est-il de la
forêt privée puisque la forêt public
c'est certes 5 millions d'HECT en
métropole mais la forêt privée c'est 12
millions d'hectares et qui
malheureusement ont été largement
victimes des incendies donc comment
venir accompagner une structuration une
meilleure gestion dans la forêt privée
dans ce budget visiblement il y a un
changement de plafond de TP sur le CNPF
mais qui n'est pas accompagné de
financement a priori donc voilà quels
sont vos propositions en ce sens et puis
donc j'ai la parole je voulais juste un
petit topo sur le volet de l'élevage
vous avez parlé sur le ministre du
malaise des agriculteurs grandissant et
donc qu'en est-il aujourd'hui des
réponses qu'on peut apporter à ces
agriculteurs effectivement en matière de
cause miroir vous en avez parlé mais on
voit pas forcément beaucoup d'éléments
concrets sur le terrain qu'en est-il des
traités de libre-échange puisqu'on
entend dire que il réapparaîtrait dans
le premier trimestre 2023 donc Mercosur
Australie Mexique avec on le sait des
contingents de viande bovine important
et enfin qu'en est-il de d'une fameuse
directive d'une directive qui serait
étudié aujourd'hui à ce jour au
Parlement européen qui consisterait à
inclure les petits élevages de 158 GB
sous le régime des ICPE donc là autant
dire qu'en tant que contrainte je pense
que nos agriculteurs vont être chargés
d'un fardeau qui va vraiment les
préoccuper merci Monsieur ministre
Fabien Guess suivi de Franck montoger
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
monsieur ministre de l'Agriculture à la
sécurité alimentaire le la sécurité
alimentaire étant extrêmement importante
moi je juge vous interroge sur un aspect
comment on peut parler de sécurité
alimentaire lorsqu'on est en train de
continuer à signer à tour de bras des
traités libre-échange qui mettent en
difficulté nos propres agriculteurs
agricultrices dans une compétition
déloyale des loyal au moins 10 ans
social et environnementales
donc j'ai deux questions précises je
veux pas être trop long quand c'est
qu'on aura le débat sur le CETA vous
avez été quand même ministre des
Relations et le Parlement et vous et
vous ne l'avez pas inscrit à l'ordre du
jour je rappelle quand même que c'est le
gouvernement qui a la main sur cette
question là vous avez fait un choix et
en tant que ministre de ne pas le mettre
sur la table ici au Sénat pourquoi et
quand et comment
je rappelle que nous avons voté une
proposition de résolution à l'unanimité
moins quelques abstention pour inscrire
alors du jour et la deuxième chose c'est
que la dernière semaine de la présidence
de la France de la Commission européenne
la Nouvelle-Zélande et là comme c'est un
accord de seconde génération mais que
l'ensemble des gouvernements maintenant
sont la même parce que personne ne voit
que à chaque fois que ça parle devant
les parlements nationaux c'est compliqué
donc du coup retrait et on n'aura pas le
droit d'avoir un débat sur le traité
avec la Nouvelle-Zélande donc est-ce que
vous en tant que ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la sécurité
alimentaire vous êtes favorable à ce que
l'ensemble des traités libre-échange
passe et soit ratifié devant les
parlements nationaux voilà je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Fabien la parole
est à ensuite à Jean-Pierre Moga merci
monsieur le ministre à trois sujets très
rapidement d'abord le sujet de l'eau
tous nos départements sont sont
concernés le mien le Gers de manière de
manière importante vous le vous le savez
dans ce budget il y a des crédits
d'investissement qui seront fléchés
utilisés à cet effet je pense que la la
problématique extrêmement compliquée de
l'eau ne serait de se résoudre pas
exclusivement avec des investissements
et qu'il faut aussi des démarches
territoriales pour aller dans le bon
sens et parmi ces démarches il y en a
une qui a été déployée il y a trois ans
et demi qui viennent de faire l'objet
d'une évaluation c'est celle des projets
territoriaux de gestion de l'eau les
ptge les fameux PTG e qui ont été lancés
je crois en 2019
un rapport vient d'être rendu par les
conseils généraux à la management du au
développement durable et et à
l'agriculture et l'espace rural je sais
pas si vous avez eu connaissance il est
très très intéressant et en substance il
dit je partage ça que c'est dans une
approche collective d'emblée de
l'ensemble des partis prenantes à
l'échelle des bassins hydrographiques
qu'on arrivera à progresser et peut-être
à éviter des situations de blocage tels
qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui et dont on
ne sait pas se sortir quand on vient
dedans quoi pour dire les choses très
clairement alors que les agriculteurs
ont besoin d'investissement pour
justement par rapport à l'eau qui leur
est absolument nécessaire sans compter
les autres usagers de l'eau qui doivent
être évidemment aussi prendre pris en
compte donc je voulais vous demander
quels sont vos intentions à cet égard
l'influence aviaire que vous avez évoqué
qui touche aussi et à ce moment mon
département je voudrais vous faire
passer un message il faut aussi protéger
les modes d'élevage autarciques les
petits il faut pas les faire disparaître
si c'est le cas s'il disparaissent
d'abord pour eux c'est dramatique et je
peux vous dire que je rencontre moi des
éleveurs ampleur par rapport à à cette
question là ils sont très très inquiets
par rapport à à la sauce entre
guillemets à laquelle ils vont être
mangés à cet égard et et c'est ce sont
des vecteurs d'images positives pour nos
territoires là où ils sont et évidemment
de qualité et scientifiquement il n'a
pas été démontré que ce type d'élevage
était à l'origine d'infection donc voilà
je voudrais avoir votre avis là-dessus
et dernier point hyper rapide vous avez
parlé des assurances et je partage voilà
tout ce qui a été fait on a voté les
textes etc il y a pas de problème par
rapport à ça comment allez-vous vous
arranger de la fameuse moyenne olympique
qui renvoie aux règles de l'OMC et qui
reste qui risque d'être un facteur de
non compréhension et de non-adhésion des
agriculteurs à la démarche assurantielle
merci merci Franck Jean-Pierre Maugat
ensuite Henri Cabanel
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je
souhaite vous poser deux questions comme
vous le savez nos territoires et
particulièrement le miel le
Lot-et-Garonne que vous connaissez bien
sont de plus en plus touchés par des
épisodes de gel au printemps et de
sécheresse en été ces derniers sont
dévastateurs pour les cultures et
provoquent des pertes importantes de
récolte comme c'est malheureusement
encore le cas cette année sur les
productions de pruneaux dans mon
département de noisette pour la
l'arboriculture etc dans ce contexte
quel accompagnement l'État
et les producteurs les producteurs
pardon peuvent-ils attendre de l'État
compte tenu du dérèglement climatique
ces aléas vont être amenés à se
reproduire plus fréquemment de leur mon
collègue parait de la moyenne olympique
quel cadre pérenne peut-être mis en
place pour soutenir nos agriculteurs et
lutter contre l'irrégularité pardon
croissante des récoltes deuxièmement je
souhaitais vous interroger au studio au
sujet du stockage de l'eau je conviens
tout à fait que cela ne relève pas
entièrement de votre périmètre mais la
vie du ministre de l'agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire est
essentielle sur cette question comment
notre agriculture va-t-elle s'adapter
aux déficit hydriques de plus en plus
fréquent monsieur le ministre quel est
votre opinion sur le stockage de l'eau
par retenu colinéaire
de manière plus générale comment peut-on
selon vous lutter contre l'impact de ces
dérèglements hydriques comment peut-on
préparer sur le plan budgétaire
et que prévoyez-vous sur sur ce plan à
court et en moyenne terme enfin
pensez-vous qu'une
mutation des cultures est inévitable je
vous remercie
juste dans les temps Henri Cabanel
ensuite Jean-Jacques Michaud merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vais revenir quelques
instants sur ce qu'a évoqué ma collègue
Françoise Ferrat contre sur le mal-être
des agriculteurs donc elle vous
demandait la feuille de route de la mise
en œuvre de ces de la volonté de votre
pdcesseur avec une enveloppe que vous
avez donc que vous avez annoncé et vous
avez nommé un coordinateur monsieur
Lenoir qui est en charge donc de mettre
en place ce qui était prévu c'était fin
2022 une cellule départementale dans
chaque département voilà donc
apparemment il y a un peu de retard
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi il y a autant
de retard alors que vous avez eu un âme
pour le mettre en place j'avais déposé
la main de main justement sur la volonté
de créer une observatoire justement sur
ces mesures qui a été jugé et recevoir
de la même je voudrais vous entendre sur
ce sujet puisque l'actuel ministre de
l'économie qui était à l'époque au
ministre de l'agriculture en 2012
avait déjà pris donc des mesures pour ce
mal-être mais il a fallu attendre 10 ans
pour voir que effectivement ce n'est ça
ne correspondait pas peut-être à la
réalité donc je voudrais savoir si
éventuellement il est possible de mettre
en place donc un observatoire pour
effectivement limiter donc les impacts
de ce mal-être vous avez évoqué aussi
l'installation et notre problème
effectivement c'est que pour une
excellation il y a deux à trois départs
à la retraite et il faut effectivement
trouver des moyens vous avez pris des
mesures concernant la transmission je
n'y reviendrai pas en passant donc de
300 à 500.000 euros le plafond
d'exonération des droits de mutation
mais le problème majeur au-delà du
revenu que vous avez évoqué qui n'est
pas très attractif pour la nouvelle
génération c'est un problème de foncier
et sur le Fossier moi je voudrais vous
entendre sur les affaires qui sont
légitimes sur ce foncier et les moyens
que qu'elles n'ont pas suffisamment en
Occitanie dans notre région et je
remercie donc la présidente d'Elga et
l'a mis en place donc un système de
portage financier mais toutes les
régions ne sont pas dans ce système-là
donc moi j'avais émis l'idée à l'époque
que les établissements publics fonciers
est une partie de leur impôts donc
fléchés sur les affaires qu'en
pensez-vous
merci beaucoup
chaud ensuite la présidente
Marie-Christine Chauvin
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
attirer votre attention sur deux sujets
qui m'ont été rapportés par les actes
par les agriculteurs de mon territoire
et je vous parlerai pas de prédation ce
soir le premier ça c'est quand même le
sujet de l'élevage et parce que les
éleveurs ont été surpris d'apprendre la
non prise en compte pour les icchen des
surfaces collectives dans la mise en
oeuvre de l'éco-régime pour les
exploitations transhumantes ça porte sur
quand même un quart de la surface
transhuman des Pyrénées c'est 4000
éleveurs et 20 millions d'euros qui sont
en jeu là dessus
le deuxième qui est de la même veine
c'est l'introduction d'un critère de
chargement plancher à 0,2
UGB par hectare et ceci est un
chargement qui est impossible sur
certains sur certaines territoires le
deuxième point c'est plutôt par rapport
à la grippe à vierge c'est sur des il
est prévu dans le PLF une enveloppe d'un
milliard d'euros vous l'avez dit pour la
gestion de cette grille et je voulais
attirer votre attention sur les
producteurs de palmipède notamment en
occitane ni qui pourrait être exclu de
l'aide compensatoire parce que c'était
de ne viserait que les producteurs
situés en zone touchée directement et
vous l'avez dit les fournisseurs de
canetons sont implantés dans l'ouest de
la France et il y a bon nombre
d'agriculteurs qui eux sont ailleurs que
dans les zones directement touchées qui
ne peuvent pas travailler voilà un petit
peu les deux questions que je voulais
vous poser merci beaucoup Jean-Jacques
la présence du groupe d'études d'élevage
Marie-Christine Chauvin ensuite Amel
gaker
merci présidente monsieur le ministre
j'aurais vous avez entendu l'élevage
revient souvent donc j'aurai également
de nombreuses questions à vous poser
c'est pourquoi je me permettrai de vous
inviter à venir rencontrer le groupe
d'études élevage une fois le budget
passé bien sûr mais je pense que ce
temps de partage serait très important
ma question de ce jour est relative à la
crise de la surproduction que connaît la
filière porcine bio comme d'autres
filières bio d'ailleurs mais à ce jour
les 700 producteurs de pores bio font
face à des difficultés conjonctuelles
importantes leur surproduction est
évaluée à 25 voire 30% par rapport à la
demande le marché allemand c'est
également tassé alors évidemment dans le
même temps le cours moyen du port du
port inconnu une envolée spectaculaire
en 2022 et dans ce contexte il serait
temps de croire que cette filière
porcine est en très bonne santé et en
réalité ce n'est que partiellement le
cas et ce n'est pas le cas de la filière
bio donc des groupements et des
producteurs de cette filière bio qui
appelle à l'aide car ils font face à des
problématiques spécifiques alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
très simple quelle solution
entendez-vous apporter à ces producteurs
sous quelle forme dans quel délai est-ce
des aides d'urgence et un plan
d'accompagnement pour un passage
momentané ou définitif à la filière
porcine traditionnelle je pense que
c'est également une façon d'envisager
les choses et pour ceux qui sont près de
la retraite comment les accompagner sur
un plan de cessation d'activité je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Amel gaker
ensuite pierre lourd
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans ce contexte d'explosion du
coup de l'énergie c'est la situation de
la filière en d'hiver que je souhaite
évoquer
je pourrais parler des arboriculteurs
des éleveurs des producteurs de pommes
de terre également sous tension mais la
situation des andiers plus alarmante car
particulièrement énergivore en
électricité il n'est plus question
d'urgence mais de survie de la filière
et de milliers d'emplois la situation
est insoutenable notamment pour 30% des
producteurs qui aujourd'hui sont en
situation de renégociation de leur
contrat d'électricité pour exemple je
vais vous citer la situation de la
producteur dont la facture est passée de
150000 euros en 2021 à 300.000 euros en
2022 à 800.000 euros en 2023 je sais que
vous êtes à l'écoute et en contact avec
cette filière vous avez annoncé
récemment l'application d'un amortisseur
électricité par contre une mesure
insuffisante complexe et surtout qui ne
permet pas
les semaines à venir les mois à venir de
manière sereine selon les producteurs
concernés donc au-delà de dispositifs de
soutien inadaptés à la situation des
filières très énergivores peut-on aller
urgemment vers un plan pérenne de survie
simple pérenne comme je le disais et qui
permettra en tout cas à ces filières de
passer les quelques semaines à venir je
vous remercie merci beaucoup Amel pierre
bouh ensuite Daniel salmon monsieur le
ministre on a déjà évoqué les contrôles
qui se multiplient auprès des
agriculteurs français
à travers la DRAC la DDA la ddp lofb
ainsi de suite et qui est en complet
déséquilibre par rapport aux produits
importés en gros 3000 agents pour sur le
dos des agriculteurs français
300 pour contrôler les produits qui
rentrent en France avec des scandales
bien connus sur le sésame et ainsi de
suite
je voulais vous proposer tout simplement
de rétablir l'équilibre vous en enlevez
101200 sur les agriculteurs et vous les
mettez en contrôle des produits entrants
est-ce que c'est possible pour vous
questionner pierre de la brièveté Daniel
salmon Sud Bernard
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire j'insiste sur
ce point d'abord j'aimerais savoir
quelle différence vous faites entre
souveraineté alimentaire et
autosuffisance alimentaire parce que
j'ai l'impression que dans l'esprit de
certains cela se confond un peu
et sinon allons sur l'agriculture bio
qui a le souci elle du lien à la terre
qui a un souci et qui est vraiment une
agriculture résiliente et je pense que
cette
cette filière qui est en difficulté
elle est tout à fait à même de répondre
au défi du réchauffement climatique et
de l'effondrement de la biodiversité et
je trouve que vous n'avez pas envoyé
dans le PLF 2023 un signal fort à cette
à cette filière qui en a vraiment besoin
vous avez dit tout à l'heure pas
d'interdiction sans solution ça
m'inquiète un petit peu c'est-à-dire
il y a un moment faut faire des
priorités aussi que pensez-vous de la
lutte pour éviter la disparition des
pollinisateurs je pense que là il y a
peut-être un sujet de priorité sinon
nombreuses questions étaient posées
concernant l'affianza arrière
quelle est la responsabilité de la
filière d'élevage intensif est-ce qu'il
y avait des vrais études
épidémiologiques aujourd'hui on sait que
tous les petits éleveurs payent très
cher les éleveurs en plein air également
et bien est-ce qu'on a des vraies études
sur le sur le sujet donc je vais me
contenter de ces questions là pour
l'instant merci et surtout que j'ai plus
de temps merci
Daniel
Bernard buis pardon excuse-moi merci
présidente monsieur le ministre
rapidement trois questions la première
puisqu'elle a pas été posée concerne la
prédation dans la Drôme cette année les
attaques de loups à l'envers des brebis
ont été en explosion puisque 860 brebis
sont perdus et je passe aussi Lens les
autres bêtes donc il y a des attentes
fortes du monde agricole je sais qu'on
va avoir un nouveau plan loup donc je
pense que là dedans il va falloir
vraiment avancer sérieusement en ce qui
concerne notamment la protection des
chaînes troupeau avec le seuil minimal
de bête pour que l'espèce soit viable
qui avait été fixée à 500 donc comment
arriver à cette régulation et puis
envisager à terme le déclassement du
loup dans la convention de Berne ma
deuxième question porte sur le chèque
alimentaire l'idée telle toujours en
train de germer peut-on espérer récolter
sa mise en œuvre courant 2023
enfin ma dernière question porte sur la
situation des syndicats d'irrigations
donc en Drôme premier département
agricole d'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes le
syndicat d'irrigation m'interpelle sur
la flambée du prix de l'électricité
indispensable pour pouvoir pomper l'eau
et l'envoyer sous pression dans les
parcelles cultivées il semblerait que
les aides annoncées par le gouvernement
pour les collectivités ne permettent pas
ou mal au syndicat d'irrigation
d'absorber le choc y a-t-il un trou dans
la raquette si tel est le cas que
peut-on faire inférieur de budgétaire
pour leur apporter une solution
aujourd'hui malgré les aides annoncées
le coût de l'irrigation à l'hectare
serait multiplié par 4 ou 5 et ne
permettrait plus une rentabilité de la
parcelle aujourd'hui des agriculteurs
d'un visage carrément pas de semer vu
les prix annoncés
merci beaucoup je présente mes excuses à
Dominique Serge et Yves que j'avais
zappé dans la liste donc Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne avec mes excuses
alors néanmoins madame la Présidente je
vais être amenée à poser un petit peu
les mêmes questions mais je vais quand
même le faire que Bernard buis puisque
je voulais parler de la prédation
également à Monsieur le Ministre le
seuil de survie de l'espèce qui est fixé
à 500 individus est atteint depuis
longtemps l'Office français de la
biodiversité en dénombré 921 en juin
dernier il convient maintenant de
maintenir de contenir sa prolifération
au risque que le plan national Lou
2018-2023 et les activités d'élevages ne
se transforment dans sa prochaine
mouture 2023 2028 en un plan de
sauvegarde des femmes et des hommes qui
produisent notre alimentation préserve
et entretiennent notre environnement
alors qu'elles vont être monsieur le
ministre vos propositions pour lutter
contre la surpopulation des loups qui ne
me permet pas une cohabitation avec le
pastoralisme il y a urgence à agir face
à l'extension massive des territoires
qu'occupent les loups devant la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'Assemblée nationale le 21 septembre
dernier vous avez expliqué que le statut
du loup doit évoluer rapidement compte
tenu de la menace vous avez rappelé la
nécessaire négociation européenne et que
vous lanceriez fin septembre au nom de
la France avec l'Union européenne alors
pouvez-vous nous dire où en sont ces
négociations pour obtenir le
déclassement du loup d'espèces super
protégé à protéger et en fin
dernièrement dans notre hémicycle lors
d'une séance de questions d'actualité
vous avez annoncé la création d'une
seconde brigade loup c'est très
important effectivement alors cette
seconde brigade loup est-ce qu'elle est
présente dans le PLF est-ce qu'il y a
des crédits qui existent déjà ou sinon
par quels moyens financier sera-t-elle
créée et enfin sur toujours en lien
aussi quand même avec le pastoralisme
dans mon département les éleveurs
fromagers subissent eux aussi une
importante augmentation de leur facture
énergétique et d'explosion des coûts et
puis le de l'alimentation pour le bétail
malgré tout l'énergie pour faire
fonctionner les infrastructures
l'énergie pour la conservation froide
les coûts de livraison augmentent comme
augmentent les coûts pour les
entreprises les PME les collectivités
qui bénéficient elles déjà d'une aide de
l'État alors quelle mesure de soutien
peuvent envisager ces éleveurs fromager
qui font déjà ce qui sont déjà durement
touchés par la prédation dans mon
département merci Dominique Serge mériou
ensuite Yves Boulou
ministre madame madame la Présidente moi
d'abord j'ai noté
l'appellation de souveraineté
alimentaire ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire ce qui
pour moi est important j'espère que
c'est pas que des mots mais je fais je
fais confiance parce que je pense que la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est un
problème auquel on va être confronté
dans les
années à venir en moyenne terme si on ne
prend pas garde à la dérive sur laquelle
on est parti on l'a noté dans le rapport
avec Laurent Duplomb et
Pierre lourot on a quand même une
inquiétude d'une phrase qui
exporte de moins en moins qui est passé
du deuxième rang au cinquième rang
mondial et le France qui importe de plus
en plus
la moitié de des produits consommés en
France pratiquement provient de
l'importation ce qui est quand même un
signe très inquiétant
ça vient effectivement d'une perte de
compétitivité l'agriculture française je
vais pas revenir sur les causes qui sont
multifactorielles qui ont été qui ont
été largement évoqués mais ça se fait au
prix d'un triple manquement d'abord pour
les agriculteurs auxquels on a du mal à
rémunérer la fonction de production mais
c'est quand même un vrai problème et
d'abord pour les consommateurs aussi et
notamment pour les catégories sociales
les plus défavorisées qui
compte tenu des problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat n'ont pas accès à une
alimentation française de qualité mais
doivent se retourner vers une
alimentation souvent importée et de
qualité parfois médiocres parce qu'elle
n'est elle n'est absolument pas
contrôlée
moi je voulais évoquer bien sûr sur les
questions d'irrigation mais l'irrigation
parce que dans le Sud-Ouest il n'y a pas
d'agriculture sans eau et il n'y a pas
de production sans eau il n'y a pas de
qualité du produit sans eau alors moi je
l'aborderai plutôt sur sur le problème
des des grosses retenues colinéaires qui
permettent de de soutenir les tiages des
rivières et parce que je pense que c'est
retenu peuvent être un support de la
biodiversité on a ce cet exemple en
Dordogne avec une rivière sur lequel on
a un barrage qui a été fait et une
réserve il y a une vingtaine d'années et
on maintient donc la biodiversité
donc je voudrais vraiment qu'on le
présente en positif et en dernier point
sur le chèque alimentaire je passe sur
tous les autres points parce que je vois
que ça presse mais sur le chèque
alimentaire est-ce qu'on pourrait
contourner les les
la distribution et regardez s'il y a pas
moyen travailler avec des organisations
caritatives qui pourraient être ceux qui
connaissent bien le public en difficulté
etc etc
c'est pas dans le budget il veut Boulou
ensuite ensuite ensuite ensuite ensuite
Sébastien plat
il y en a beaucoup vous avez du succès
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre il
s'agit de retraite de retraite agricole
le calcul des retraites des agriculteurs
sur celles des salariés et des
indépendants
et notamment via le calcul de la
retraite sur les seuls 25 meilleures
années de revenus merci
beaucoup je vous demande d'être encore
plus rapide parce que le ministre de
nous quitter à 19h55
et c'est le président l'archet qui
l'attend donc il y a voilà
mais il faut qu'il réponde quand même
donc voilà
j’éprouve quelques difficultés à
percevoir la trajectoire en novatrice de
ce budget que vous nous proposez
puisqu'on prend on prend les mêmes les
mêmes mesures et on recommence j'ai
l'intention de dire mais bon la question
qui est centrale et moi qui je vous pose
c'est quelle est la stratégie de
développement agricole que vous
souhaitez dans un contexte budgétaire
tendu puisque l'endettement de l'État
est très élevé et puis nous sommes dans
un contexte des armements fiscal ensuite
la pérennisation du Tod c'est une très
bonne chose l'assurance MRC aussi mais
j'aimerais être rassuré sur le fait que
les compagnies d'assurance seront en
capacité de la mettre en oeuvre dès 2023
et comment surtout compter vous attaquer
très directement la question de la
moyenne olympique qui constituent un
frein majeur je donne un exemple moi je
suis vigneron la moyenne olympique après
3 années de grêle et de gel est à veinct
de litres hectares donc j'ai aucun
intérêt à m'assurer et c'est un vrai
majeur aujourd'hui à la mise en oeuvre
de la de la MRC en particulier sur sur
nos types de culture et enfin une
dernière question sur les abattoirs de
proximité dans nos massifs qui sont en
grande difficulté
à la fois pour des contrées sanitaires
et surtout des moyens financiers les
honorer le structurant dans nos
montagnes ils sont portés à bout de bras
par les collectivités locales mais ça
suffit pas donc comment vous niveau de
l'État comptez-vous les accompagner
merci
merci beaucoup Franck mais non-ville
ensuite Christian Redon sarrazzi merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre quand on arrive à 7h vivement
dans le dans le rythme des questions
beaucoup de sujets ont été ont été
évoqués Théodore je voulais évoquer
aussi le la multirisque agricole et
notamment le niveau de de préparation
des des assureurs
alors moi je me concentre reste plutôt
sur la partie
du coût de l'énergie et ça vient
peut-être en complément de notre
collègue
Amel gaccare
effectivement il y a eu
différentes annonces concernant les
amortisseurs des boucliers tarifaires
mais effectivement aujourd'hui il y a
encore des des trous dans la raquette et
notamment me semble-t-il dans le domaine
des TPE et notamment de dans le domaine
de l'agriculture puisque je crois que ce
qui est annoncé pour 2023 donc c'est des
des dispositions
d'abord amortisseur des dispositions
permettant amortir le coût de l'énergie
mais pour des des comptes des compteurs
de puissance inférieure à 36 kg en pair
et effectivement il y a sur un certain
nombre de productions et vous avez venus
il y a quelques semaines dans notre
département dans le Grand Est au niveau
des producteurs de pommes de terre et là
aussi il y a un vrai sujet et un vrai
sujet moi j'ai à titre d'exemple donc
j'ai un producteur en matière de
stockage
un producteur donc qui qui évoquait donc
des
de 70 euros par mégawattheure qui est en
phase de de
renégociation et malgré le malgré les
dispositions
subiraient une hausse de 400 %, donc
juste vraiment
très difficile à supporter pour ce style
de production merci merci Franck
Christian Redon sarrazzi pierre Kuiper
de monsieur le ministre je souhaitais
évoquer avec vous la situation du
renouvellement des générations mais pas
de agriculteurs de ceux des vétérinaires
qu'on a déjà un peu évoqué afin que le
ministre d'agriculture qui sera en poste
en 2030 de se trouve pas dans la
situation que connaît aujourd'hui votre
collègue de la santé il est absolument
nécessaire de prendre dès à présent les
bonnes décisions vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir qu'il y a un projet sur ce sujet
en nouvelle-aquitaine région où les
filières animales sont très présentes et
le problème sanitaire assez prégnant
l'influence air dans le Sud-Ouest y est
pour beaucoup la santé animale la santé
humaine sont indissociables c'est le
cœur du projet d'école vétérinaire que
porte donc la région à Limoges wannels
donc une seule santé ce n'est pas
seulement une école c'est tout un
écosystème avec les praticiens
vétérinaires les formations médicales
humaines les écoles d'agro les
formations universitaires et de
laboratoires associés donc en biologie
en sciences de la vie et de la santé les
entreprises du secteur monsieur le
ministre êtes-vous prêt donc à
accompagner ce projet et lui donner les
moyens nécessaires aux côtés de la
région nouvelle Aquitaine et de tous les
acteurs territoriaux merci beaucoup
Christian pierre creeper sans suite
Laurent saumon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre la
Commission européenne veut supprimer
l'utilisation d'un herbicide utilisée
sur la culture de l'endive de la
chicorée et du haricot ce produit
s'appelle le bon allant il a pour
matière active la peinture Aline qui
doit perdre son autorisation
d'utilisation prochainement
la Commission européenne a demandé à
chaque État membre de se prononcer avant
le 4 novembre dernier
j'aimerais avoir votre réponse par
rapport à cette interrogation
communautaire sachant que si ce produit
est supprimé si la France ne l'autorise
pas la production n'a pas de produit de
remplacement donc nous sommes dans une
situation de perte de production
d'endives ça se rajoute conditions
énergétiques etc ou les coûts
énergétiques vont cinq fois plus x 5 x 6
mais c'est vrai pour la production de
pommes c'est vrai pour la production de
pommes de terre et puis une dernière
question nous abordons en 2023 la
dernière utilisation de dérogation des
néonicotinoïdes sur la betterave
sucrière
quel est votre position pour 2023 sur sa
reconduction enfin pour son efficacité
et pour 2024 sachant que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui de produits de
remplacement qui soit efficace merci
merci Pierre Laurent saumon suite
et cartonnerie malgré une revalorisation
des prix par les industriels le compte
tenu d'inflation chimie ces derniers les
surfaces qui font passer de 23500
hectares avaient en 2021 à 18700
possiblement en 2022 donc ma question
c'est de savoir si vous allez aider
cette filière par une aide
conjoncturelle c'est-à-dire une aide
directe à la production comme il la
demande de si il va y avoir une aide
structurelle dans le cadre des écorriges
et de leur permettre d'obtenir compte
tenu de la production de protéines de
pommes de terre de pouvoir avoir un
point supplémentaire dans le cas des
écorigines de faciliter la production de
pommes de terre particulière a notamment
en termes d'irrigation à savoir la
réutilisation des eaux chargées
résiduelles donc issus des situations
d'épuration par exemple
de l'usine elle-même et puis enfin
d'intégrer l'activité régulière dans des
dispositifs de modernisation d'outils
industriels ça c'était ma première
question la plus importante ne revient
pas sur les endives mais j'ai déjà
sollicité vos services à ce sujet qui
sont véritablement grande difficulté et
enfin une dernière petite question c'est
de pensez-vous des capitalisation de
l'élevage et les risques qu'il y aura
demain sur les entrants dans les usines
dans les unités de méthanisation
merci beaucoup Laurent Micheline Jacques
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
ministre vous avez annoncé dans votre
propos liminaire une augmentation des
crédits pour soutenir l'agriculture
ultramarine et je m'en réjouis le plan
chlordécone 2021 2027 oriente plus
particulièrement la Rochelle la
recherche sur la compréhension de
l'évolution de cette molécule dans la
nature et vente et éventuelle les
éventuels méthode de décontamination
quelle place prévoyez-vous de faire à la
diversification de la production que
pensez-vous du colza pour l'usage de la
chimie verte en vue de faire des
Outre-mer des territoires d'innovation
très bien je vous remercie j'ai une
dernière question de la part d'Olivier
Ritman mais je suis sûr que vous la
devinez sur le décret d'application de
la loi sans passe tout si vous a
beaucoup sollicité sur le sujet
il semblerait que le décret
d'application avant de passer au Conseil
d'État soit déjà dans la presse donc je
voulais avoir quelques informations sur
ce décret d'application de la loi sans
passe tous auquel nous regardons avec
beaucoup d'attention
merci vous avez donc 27 minutes
mais je vous ferai un mot pour le
Président
je commence par les quatre sujets qui
sont revenus à plusieurs motifs c'est
pour éviter d'y revenir
au prédation accords de libre-échange
question alimentaire et notamment le
chèque il me semble que c'est des
éléments qui reviennent à plusieurs
reprises je sens que le monsieur gay
aimerait bien que je réponde tout de
suite sur la question du libre-échange
alors il y a plusieurs sujets il y a la
méthode et puis il y a le fond des
questions ça a été posée par un certain
nombre d'entre vous et puis après la
question de l'application
je vous donne ce que je pense du sujet
d'abord on a un sujet global de méthode
d'approche sur les accords de
libre-échange je vous disiez monsieur
sénateur si on fait de la réciprocité
stricte il y aura plus l'accord de
libre-échange le votre voisin de deux
rangs disait il faut quand même
préserver
le commerce du vin et spiritueux et donc
il faut lever les contraintes des
Américains alors il me semble qu'il va
falloir qu'on se mette pardon je le dis
un peu à bruptement d'accord dans ce
pays soit on veut exportateur si on veut
plus être exportateur mais on pourra pas
être là sans l'autre
le libre-échange s'accepte que nous
puissions exporter donc c'est des
questions de compétitivité que ce que
souligne monsieur Dupont et le
distorsion qui sont pour beaucoup
d'entre elles c'est un élément qu'on
aura à débattre l'issue de vos de votre
rapport que vous avez fait avec d'autres
collègues du de cette commission souvent
la concurrence elle est
intracommunautaires et le terrain qu'on
a perdu il est souvent
intracommunautaire donc c'est pas les
accords de libre-échange de soit on a
décidé de plus vendre de lait plus
vendre de céréales plus vendent de vins
et spiritueux mais il faudra pas
demander à ceux à qui on le vend
de que eux ne puissent pas faire du
commerce avec nous quand nous nous
pourrions nous aurions droit de faire du
commerce avec ça marchera pas comme ça
donc il va falloir juste il va falloir
se le dire deuxième élément pour
répondre mais c'est là avec l'autre
c'est pas l'un sans l'autre je suis
désolé de le dire comme ça parce qu'il
faut que c'est une question de cohérence
si on veut on est tous à regretter la
perte de souveraineté française en
disant à l'époque nous exportions des
fruits et légumes nous exportions du
sucre nous exportions et nous le faisons
plus faut savoir
j'irai après parce que ça me donne donc
on a besoin premièrement c'est celui-là
moi je pense qu'on doit assumer une
capacité exportatrice ça me permet quand
même de répondre à la question du
sénateur seulement si j'ai pas de
mémoire sur
souvreté autarcie
autosuffisance j'ai entendu au taxi
dans un modèle de dérèglement climatique
excusez-moi je veux dire un truc qui est
un peu peut-être ballot mais si vous
dites j'ai besoin de sang je produis
sans quand vous avez une année comme
celle-là vous faites comment
ma grand-mère disait pour en avoir assez
pour en avoir trop je dis la même chose
mais vous
donc un moment dans un modèle de
dérèglement climatique on a besoin
d'échange à un moment quand monsieur
Poutine fait de l'alimentation une arme
alimentaire et qui décide de bloquer les
ports on a besoin d'en avoir un peu plus
pour en donner un autre
mais si auto suffisant c'est que je
couvre simplement mes besoins on a
besoin d'être autosuffisant au niveau
mondial
notre sujet il est celui-là pardon de le
dire quand vous allez au niveau européen
j'étais en Algérie avec la première
ministre j'ai rencontré mes collègues de
le cede tous disent comment on va faire
pour nourrir nos populations et d'où
personne se pose la question de cette
question là en disant on couvre nos
besoins et après on se fiche de ce qui
se passe dans la frontière voisine de
Méditerranée ce qui se passe en Amérique
du Sud parce qu'ils auraient un accident
climatique ça marche pas
il y a plus que jamais besoin d'échanges
la question après c'est qu'on est des
règles qui soient des règles loyales
ah non mais je préférais commencer par
un plaidoyer non pas trop de mots que
l'agriculture est plutôt réputée pour
défendre les intérêts agricoles et pas
être très allant à aller aux accords
agricoles aux accords de libre-échange
bon très bien enfin il faut quand même
se dire des choses si on veut être
sérieux la souveraineté ça nécessite des
échanges et en dérèglement climatiques
il en faudra sans doute plus et 3 je
n'ai pas honte de dire que nous avons
des filières d'excellence qu'il faut
qu'on puisse continuer à voir prospérer
à l'extérieur de nos frontières très
bien
attendez ah bah alors d'accord donc ce
n'est pas refermé sur nos sur nos
espèces alors laissez-moi finir monsieur
gay
non non c'est pas éculé parce qu'on est
plutôt dans un moment on dit il faut
plus d'accord de libre-échange non non
c'est pas éculé il y a un malentendu
pardon il y a un malentendu
alors je finis la question c'est la
loyauté des échanges donc c'est les
clauses de réciprocité on a on a mis
soyons honnêtes et modeste mon
prédécesseur ça me permet d'être
doublement modeste à cranter que le fait
que dans les accords internationaux on
est la capacité à mettre des clauses de
réciprocité
la culture générale de la Commission
européenne n'était pas de mettre ces
clauses là c'est plutôt une culture de
bah on fait jouer la compétition les
meilleurs et qui était une clause qui
était au fond de dire ben si le la
production agricole se fait ailleurs
philosophie qui traîne un peu c'est
celle là on vendra des Airbus et on
n'aura pas besoin d'aller vendre de
ouais il y a une philosophie comme ça
qui existe bon la cloche de réciprocité
permet de d'essayer de compter cette
question là c'est largement devant nous
c'est à dire qu'il faut désormais que
dans chaque accord international qui
soit mixte ou qui soit sans demande du
Parlement j'y reviens après monsieur gay
on puisse on puisse incrémenter des
clauses est-ce qu'on va passer du de
l'ombre à la lumière d'un coup non parce
que dans chaque débat que nous aurons
sur les accords mais c'est pas ce que
vous m'avez demandé d'ailleurs mais dans
chaque débat il faut qu'on mette quels
sont les meilleurs clauses on peut pas à
la fois aussi avoir des gens qui nous
passent leur temps à nous dire il faut
qu'on respecte les défis climatiques à
l'extérieur des frontières européennes
sans que les ne serait-ce que les
clauses climatiques et les causes de
contraintes environnementales déjà
réglerait une partie de nos questions
donc je pense qu'il faut porter le fer
sur le carboner des carbonées sur quels
sont les clauses environnementales que
vous portez et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
que essayer d'avancer mais je le dis
avec modestie parce que je sens que le
chemin est assez long là-dessus deuxième
élément voilà pour les questions
troisième élément c'est la question de
la méthode c'est les accords
internationaux et puis après vous m'avez
interrogé sur le site pardon je vais
être précis
troisième élément c'est la question de
la méthode oui c'est des accords mixtes
ou des accords non mix dans un cas le
Parlement est sollicite les parlements
sont sollicités dans d'autres cas oui je
vois très bien l'exercice qui consiste à
dire
la Commission décide toute seule alors
après il y a quand même des règles de
consultation du conseil ou du Parlement
européen c'est pas complètement il y a
un Parlement européen
quand même et donc c'est aussi assez
niveau là que peuvent se poser ces
débats moi je pense par ailleurs que
nous avons un sujet démocratique
nous vous réjouissez pas trop vite mais
nous avons un sweet démocratique c'est
que il y a quelque chose qui est gênant
dans ces accords je le dis moi c'est
peut-être que je le pense c'est on donne
un mandat à la commission ça part en
sous-marin et tout d'un coup quel jour
avant l'accord on va dire voilà l'accord
et on a besoin de construire j'ai besoin
de construire moi j'ai demandé à mes
équipes de construire de voilà les
accords qu'on a devant nous parce que la
peur n'évite pas le danger oui les
Brésiliens et Monsieur Loula faut pas se
faire d'illusions il a envie de
commercer
et donc il va avoir envie de réactiver
l'accord qui est en cours
voilà et donc qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
position
agricole qui nous paraissent importante
pour ne pas désorganiser tel ou tel
filière pour pouvoir promouvoir telle ou
telle filière et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire et deux il faut le faire dans une
forme qui ne soit pas une forme
sous-marine c'est à dire qu'on dise
qu'on est des débats parce que
je suis assez fasciné qu'on n'arrive pas
à avoir des débats troisième année
quatrième élément enfin des débats comme
on en a d'ailleurs et qui sont normaux
moi je trouve quatrième élément le CETA
alors quand j'étais midi des relations
avec le Parlement je n'ai pas inscrit
alors du jour et de vous demanderez
désormais au futur à l'actuel ministre
des Relations avec le Parlement de
c'est moche c'est pas moche mais c'est
la vérité c'est pas moche que c'est la
vérité ce n'est pas moi qui vais
déterminer lors du jour sur le CETA
je dis au passage quand même
plaisanterie mise à part pardon madame
la Présidente d'avoir été malicieux avec
vous c'est
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui le CETA
il est plutôt bénéficiaire pour la
France
non non non non
je ne dis pas le contraire je vous dis
pardon la balance comme la balance
commerciale n'est pas défavorable
on va laisser le Nice finir parce que
deuxième sujet la prédation
vous avez été deux il y en a peut-être
plusieurs je vais vous dire des choses
telles que je dépense sur la sur la
prédation de alors je crois me souvenir
de ce que j'ai dit à la commission de
l'Assemblée nationale j'essaie de pas
travailler mes propres propos mais
moi je pense qu'on a plusieurs sujets on
a un sujet de débat européen on l'a
porté avec mes collègues qui de dire le
statut est-ce qu'on peut parler du
statut de l'espèce qu'est-ce que ça
n'est pas de nature à réinterroger Berne
habitat plus important encore pour ceux
qui connaissent le sujet et vous je sais
que vous connaissez
une convention interprétative de la
Directive Habitat guide interprétatif de
la Directive Habitat et je commencerai
peut-être faire ça parce que le guide
interprétatif c'est un dialogue nous à
la commission il y a pas besoin de nous
pays européen il y a pas besoin
d'uneanimité ou autre
mais ça n'a pas résumé la situation
parce que alors il suffit pas d'avoir
raison ou d'avoir une pensée il faut
partager dans des débats européens faut
trouver de la conviction pour emmener le
maximum de gens et avoir une majorité on
sait exprimé sur les 27 qui sont
exprimés
je crois que c'est le collègue
luxembourgeois qui a dit moi je suis
défavorable mais je lui ai expliqué que
sans doute il vous croisez moins de loup
que nous mais ils arrivent peut-être
deuxième sujet il faut absolument pas
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est pour
ça que je vous dis les pistes que
j'entrevois moi et qui doit faire
l'objet d'un débat
national une discussion nationale est
par ailleurs c'est un dialogue c'est pas
c'est le MTE qui est qui est le
ministère de la transition écologique
qui charge de ces questions mais vous
reconnaîtrez je me suis un peu j'ai fait
le choix de mettre ça au débat parce que
je pense que c'est important pour
avancer
il me semble qu'on a une importante
c'est il y a on a on a plusieurs choses
un il faut qu'on se mette d'accord sur
le comptage
la méthode c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on
rétablisse de la confiance je fais
griller à faire personne simplement faut
qu'on se mette d'accord sur le comptage
parce que du comptage procède les 19%
. donc le prélèvement autorisé
premièrement c'est une question de
confiance faut pas dire aux gens si il y
en a pas s'il y en a au passage je dis
pour être honnête intellectuellement que
personne n'a dit qu'un 500 on avait
fermé le banc non non il était inscrit
non j'essaie d'être il était inscrit que
l'objectif était d'atteindre 500 sans
dire que ça non mais non c'est pas pour
jouer sur les mots non mais c'est non
mais je crois non attendez je comprends
que c'était compris comme ça mais ça
n'est pas factuellement ce qui a été dit
il n'empêche que on a un sujet c'est
donc le dénombrement deuxième sujet on a
besoin de simplifier les processus de
prélèvement quand tu as besoin de
réaliser un prélèvement dommage j'ai
commencé j'avais une intuition sur le
sujet depuis très longtemps et pourtant
je suis au Loir-et-Cher j'ai pas encore
opportun un jour
c'est qu'on a un sujet le procès c'est
beaucoup trop compliqué si on ne veut
pas effectuer le quota il suffit de s'y
prendre comme c'est aujourd'hui
et ça c'est des Espérants on a un côté à
174 on est le 15 novembre on est à 146
bon et personne nous remet en cause ça
donc on a besoin c'est les modalités de
tir
c'est les équipements
ça me permet de répondre
oui alors attention à ça parce que il y
a des départements qui vont vous dire
moi je suis un front de colonisation il
faut m'empêcher le front de
collinisation et vous dans votre
département vous a dire vous êtes sympa
mais nous ça fait 25 ans donc je
j'avance avec prudence sur ce sujet même
si mon premier intuition pour être tout
à fait honnête je pensais comme vous
mais en fait quand vous réfléchissez
bien
c'est plus compliqué que ça parce que à
côté contraint c'est normal vous
m'entendez pas d'ailleurs dans mon
propos dire ça fait partie de la
biodiversité simplement vous avez raison
je l'ai dit d'ailleurs publiquement
l'autre jour lors d'un déplacement dans
le dos je pense que ce qui me menace
c'est dans certains cas c'est l'élevage
et c'est le pastoralisme il va falloir
se le dire tranquillement là aussi
non mais l'élevage tombé non mais
d'abord le pastoralisme désormais
l'élevage avec un des choses assez
impressionnantes c'est-à-dire qu'au
moment où certains expliquent partout
qu'il faut faire de l'extensive du
pastoralisme ils expliquent pas la
meilleure solution c'est quand même de
rentrer les animaux à l'intérieur comme
ça ils seront protégés du loup théorique
en plus enfin vous voyez qu'on sache
qu'on veut
pour faire de la désespérance Agricole
vous faites exactement comme ça
donc équipement
modalités de simplification des
prélèvements et on y a travaillé on est
en train d'y travailler avec le mpe pour
faire en sorte que nous ayons des
propositions à faire pour la saison qui
va s'ouvrir pas pour le plan loot 2024
je pense que c'est un élément important
des éléments administratifs je vais très
vite mais
simplification des indemnisations
simplification des délais
de part et de financement de la
prévention ça c'est chez nous au
ministère de l'Agriculture ce que ça
peut pas avoir 12 à 18 mois pour être
enfin
c'est plus court sur l'indemnisation et
je le dis c'est le MTE mais c'est plus
long chez nous pour des raisons qui sont
comme c'est des fonds européens c'est un
peu plus compliqué mais il va falloir
qu'on essaie de trouver des solutions
pour pas que vous embauchez le berger en
janvier et vous soyez payé en décembre
parce que la trésorerie c'est le c'est
l'éleveur qu'il a fait donc ça c'est un
problème on va dire les choses comme
elles sont donc on a besoin de
travailler aussi on a besoin de tenir
compte dans l'indemnisation c'est pas la
brebis qu'on a retrouvé égorgée
seulement c'est celle qui ont disparu et
c'est celle qu'on va avorter
et c'est la perte génétique
si on reconnaît pas la pergénétique
c'est le travail de l'agriculteur et de
l'éleveur
oui et il faut il faut
j'essaie de pas être trop trop maniché
parfois ça peut être la protection
parfois ça ne l'est pas il faut assumer
aussi je me suis fait alors je me fais
plein d'amis avec ce que je suis en
train de dire hein mais j'assume ma
position parce que la désespérance et ça
ce que je veux dire d'un éleveur il se
trouve que dans le douche je suis arrivé
le matin d'une attaque faut voir l'état
de désespérance de quelqu'un on dit ah
bah c'est comme ça merci de ta
contribution à la biodiversité et par
ailleurs l'activité d'élevage elle
contribue à la biodiversité donc pour
une biodiversité on prend le risque de
faire disparaître tout un pan de
biodiversité le maintien des prairies le
réseau le réseau de tout ça contribuant
au tourisme dans des départements comme
les veaux comme le tout la département
qui sont dans cette situation là et donc
on peut pas tout sacrifier c'est c'est
c'est c'est lunaire qu'on n'arrive pas à
dire des choses aussi simplement que je
le dis avec pondération comme je le dis
enfin il faut quand même qu'on saisisse
de cette question et donc
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il faut pas
qu'on se retranche seulement dans
l'affaire européenne et Berne parce que
ça nous empêcherait d'avancer quatrième
élément il faut qu'on documente ce que
je suis en train de dire est-ce que vous
dites est-ce je sens est-ce que je
perçois de comment on peut faire
cohabiter pastoralisme il y a des
moments faut assumer que ça ne peut pas
cohabiter
que c'est compliqué à faire cohabiter ne
serait-ce que ça les agriculteurs
auraient besoin de l'entendre
ne serait-ce que ça par tous ceux qui
donnent des leçons à longueur de média
ne serait-ce que ça voilà donc voilà ce
que je voulais dire sur la prédation
comme vous avez compris c'est un sujet
oui alors la brique alors pardon dans
les mécanismes alors l'abrigades loup
alors elle est elle est plutôt
prépositionnée c'est plutôt diabolique
c'est les moyens mt-e ça dans les
Pyrénées
parce que c'est Massif Central parce que
c'est plutôt dans le Massif Central
voilà bien sûr alors après je dis on
peut pas demander il y a un réseau qui
marche très bien pardon et qu'il faut
valoriser c'est les louvetiers il faut
les former
faut les accompagner il faut les donner
d'Inde et qui leur permettent juste de
voir dans des conditions acceptables
je viens je l'ai dit
ouais j'ai des idées j'ai quelques idées
donc voilà tout ça ça me permet de dire
c'est tous ces enregistre là qu'il faut
faire et dans le plan lourd il faut dire
ça c'est possible ça c'est pas possible
ça c'est protégeable ça c'est pas
protégeable voilà j'en arrive à la
question de l'eau vous m'avez interrogé
à plusieurs reprises sur la question de
l'eau
là aussi j'aimerais qu'on arrive à poser
un débat assez tranquillement
il y a besoin mais j'essaie de répondre
à des sujets un peu la question l'eau on
y reviendra sur moi plusieurs reprises
je partage un il y a besoin d'eau on
agriculture il va falloir qu'on
l'entende partout il va falloir qu'on
l'entende le dérèglement climatique il
va produire des dérèglements et des
arythmies pluviométriques
donc il va falloir qu'on assume que dans
les périodes où il y a trop d'eau on en
récupère et que dans les périodes où il
y a pas assez d'eau en plus 3 c'est un
empêche pas qu'on puisse le faire et
c'est ça qui est désespérant dans le
projet qui est en controversé et dont on
parle c'est que ça n'empêche pas que
dans ces territoires là on a un certain
nombre de de mesures qui sont prises
pour réduire les produits
phytosanitaires pour réduire les
prélèvements c'est un projet celui qui
est controversé où on réduit dans la
période estivale des deux tiers le
prélèvement et on réduit deux un tiers
le prélèvement la période d'été et on
réduit globalement d'un tiers le
prélèvement net donc on passe de 20
millions de mètres cubes à 12 ou 13
millions de mètres cubes il y a quand
même moins d'eau qui est prélevé donc
c'est quand même un système vertueux ça
me permet de répondre à votre question
monsieur le sénateur au passage moi je
pense qu'on a besoin de construire du
collectif après faut que tout le monde
parce que dans le projet en question il
y a des associations
qui ont signé le protocole
et qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui à à
promouvoir au niveau national
l'inverse de ce qu'ils ont signé donc à
un moment faut être de bonne foi dans
cette affaire pas vous c'est pas le
sujet là c'est dès lors qu'on fait un
projet territorial on signe on signe pas
quand on signe on signe et quand c'est
purgé des questions juridiques on y va
et donc moi je fais toutes les semaines
une revue de projet pour regarder les
projets qui existent ce qu'on peut
déployer et on a besoin de travailler
sur du collectif moi je pense qu'on a
une question c'est utilisation des
ouvrages à quoi ça sert
parce que ça peut être irrigation lutte
de la maintient des étiages lutte contre
les inondations lutte contre la les
incendies
alimentation en eau potable et
d'ailleurs à la vérité et quand vous
regardez je sais plus qui l'a dit c'est
plutôt c'est les PTG oui mais oui mais
dans plein de cas c'est déjà des PTG les
projets dont on parle
mais si non mais il y a une il y a
quelque chose qui est mortifère dans le
débat qu'on a sur ces questions là la
prédation c'est la même chose c'est
retour à l'état de nature
c'est quoi et ça c'est là c'est la mort
de l'agriculture ça ou alors on revient
10 000 ans en arrière donc je pense ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas faire
des efforts sur le prélèvement des
efforts de pratique il y a des
territoires où on va faire je sais plus
qui me l'a dit il y a des cultures qu'on
ne fera plus dans certains territoires
ce que le dérèglement climatique va le
rendre impossible il faut aussi
l'assumer et je l'assumerai j'ai pas de
difficulté avec ça et donc c'est un
élément important mais donc faut qu'on
arrive à poser le débat ça nécessite
qu'on accompagne les agriculteurs qu'on
finance les ouvrages on a mis 45
millions dans le pense prendre en lance
il faut qu'on déploie mais avec une
vigilance pour dire attention c'est pas
un droit comme ça c'est chacun fait sa
part de responsabilité et quand c'est
une gouvernance collective c'est mieux
parce qu'on peut pas faire grief de tel
ou telle accaparement qui n'en est pas
un mais enfin au moins ça permet de
détendre les choses ça me permet de dire
alors question alimentaire premier
dispositif chaque alimentaire
reconnaissant que c'est un dispositif on
lui demande tout chez qualimentaire on
lui demande de question d'ailleurs au
démarrage c'est pour ça plutôt de la
question de la précarité d'un certain
nombre de gens de permettre à des gens
d'accéder à une alimentation de qualité
on lui demande de pouvoir organiser les
filières on lui demande de assumer la
transition viande vers végétale on lui
demande de faire de la qualité en lui
demandant moi je vais vous dire la
conviction g c'est impossible de tout
faire avec un chèque alimentaire d'où je
ne sais plus qu'il a dit l'idée pour moi
que
qu'on commence et ce qu'on fait c'est
peut-être vous c'est ce qu'on commence à
ce qu'on fait avec Jean-Christophe comme
on a dédié un premier fond
supplémentaire de 60 millions d'euros
via
les banques les associations en
particulier les banques alimentaires
parce que c'est première étage n'est pas
au bout de la réflexion mais il semble
que c'est un élément
il me semble que c'est un élément très
important d'essayer de travailler sur ce
sujet là première étape c'est celle là
il y a les Banques Alimentaires je pense
que dans la restauration collective ça
revient alors c'est pas ce que comme ça
que vous avez pris tout à l'heure mais
dans la restauration collective je
dirais après tout est-ce que c'est pas
la meilleure voie et moyen pour faire
découvrir à des jeunes générations qui
parfois sont assez éloignées des
questions de qualité alimentaire de leur
apporter dans ce modèle là de la
diversité plutôt que de faire un chèque
qui va se terminer au supermarché moi je
pense que c'est une bonne question de le
poser comme ça enfin j'ai presque fini
donc voilà c'est les quatre points que
je voulais évoquer
vous avez évoqué les contentieux
aéronautiques c'est bien noté de toute
façon évidemment vous en doutez que
c'est une chose qui sur lequel on va
avancer la loi s'en passe tous alors
pardon
les propositions de décret sont au
Conseil d'État depuis 30 août le Conseil
d'État a délibéré c'est peut-être pour
ça que c'est dans la presse aujourd'hui
je crois ce jour
donc
on y est presque
je trouve je pardon je trouve que c'est
dommage de dire il y a pas de modèle
alternatif faut qu'on trouve un modèle
qui soit durable et le modèle durable la
bio est est un des modèles qui porte en
soi c'est pas le seul
mais la question de dire parce que c'est
pardon vous dites monsieur Cardon a dit
il faut remettre un peu de d'urbanité
dans le monde rural et si on mettait un
peu de ruralité et d'urbanité dans le
monde urbain ça serait pas mal aussi
hein pardon vis-à-vis du monde agricole
c'est pas ce que vous avez dit mais faut
que tout le monde se comprenne dans
cette affaire là parce que c'est les
injonctions à des gens à qui on n'est
pas capable de dire comment je te paye
cette injonction là c'est que c'est
compliqué et deux je trouve qu'on ferait
défaut mais c'est mon avis personnel en
disant j'impose je pense qu'il faut
laisser tout le monde faire son chemin
et tout le monde est pas au même degré
de conscience qu'il y a des modèles qui
sont plus compliqués que d'autres à
faire transiter et que de dire il y a un
bon modèle il va y aller bon et les
méchants donc c'est pas comme ça que
vous l'avez dit mais on est on est en
train d'essayer de faire moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas ceux qui sont le
plus en avant et les plus en point de
techniquement sur les questions c'est
ceux qui sont le plus loin
c'est cela qu'il faut embarquer parce
que c'est cela qui sont les plus en
risque ça me permet au passage de
répondre à la question de Pierre Cuypers
au risque je ne veux pas lui être
désagréable mais on peut pas à la fois
dire il faut qu'on en sorte et à chaque
fois qu'on dit il va on va en sortir ou
être prévenu je parle pas des
néonicotines mais
il y a rien comme décision de 4 la
décision il y a une rencontre le 12
décembre de c'est une décision
européenne donc c'est quand même pas une
surtransmission Française 3 il va
falloir qu'on assume le fait que les CMR
1 en particulier il y a un certain
nombre de molécules on va en sortir donc
la question n'est pas de savoir si on va
échapper à la sortie la question c'est
qu'il faut qu'on mette des moyens sur la
recherche pour pour non mais c'est oui
non mais le temps est court mais parfois
à force de pas avoir vu c'est encore un
peu
ben non il y a des produits pardon il
faut qu'on en sorte et moi j'assume ça
aussi même si c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
envie d'être désagréable néonicotinoïde
on sait on sait tout le monde s'est
engagé sur des moyens tout le monde
s'est engagé sur une durée moi j'ai du
mal à penser qu'on deviendrait
facilement devant le Parlement en disant
bon bah il faut 3 ans
donc attendons alors 2023 moi je pense
qu'il faut poursuivre le processus on va
attendre les résultats l'inrae les
résultats des travaux on va regarder les
solutions alternatives on va regarder
l'accompagnement mais ne commençons pas
c'est pas ce que vous avez dit attendez
nous commençons pas par dire 2024 quand
on a même pas commencé 2023
oui mais il faut penser à 2024 sans les
néo nicotinoïdes d'abord bah si
oui mais pardon je suis impossymétrique
là mais j'essaye de dire il faut pas
l'interdiction sans solution mais il
faut qu'on cherche les solutions
bon quand même Pascal à la fin il y en
aura plus
non
vous êtes en forme vous
êtes taquin non mais je le dis parce que
c'est un sujet important il faut qu'on
assume le fait c'est pas simplement je
c'est mon sujet n'est pas de dire de
faire plaisir à tel ou tel le sujet
c'est que c'est des molécules on sait
qu'elle porte leur lot de contraintes
mais fais pas par plaisir et au niveau
européen aussi
donc monsieur le ministre me permet de
vous interrompre parce que il vous reste
énormément de questions à répondre et je
ne voudrais pas me fâcher avec le
président l'argent et encore moins avec
le récipient d'air de la décoration que
vous allez remettre que je ne connais
pas mais je veux pas me fâcher avec lui
ou elle d'ailleurs je sais pas je vous
propose peut-être juste d'évoquer
l'histoire de l'énergie voilà sur les
stockages sur la transformation et
ensuite le reste des réponses je vous
propose de nous répondre par écrit et je
vous demande la faveur de revenir au
mois de janvier
qui n'auront pas été traités jusqu'à
présent si vous acceptez voilà voilà
donc peut-être juste un peu sur les
questions énergétique en fait on a
plusieurs il y a trois dispositifs
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le dernier
c'est ce qu'on appelait guichet tout à
l'heure dans l'intervention donc là
c'est là par rapport aux endives en
particulier parce que les endives ce que
vous parlez c'est les deux autres
guichets dans lesquels il rentre pas
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai besoin que
vous me documentiez sur ces sujets là
parce que il y a pas comme les filières
sont pas homogènes dans leurs besoins
leur appel d'énergie la façon dont elle
fonctionne les individus ils en ont
besoin sur trois mois donc ils
rentraient pas du tout dans le précédent
dispositif donc nous on est en train de
travailler avec les filières pour
essayer vraiment de bonne foi de trouver
un dispositif qui colle donc faites nous
remonter je suis en contact avec j'ai à
peu près le même exemple parce que je
crois que c'est la même personne sur la
question non mais sur l'exemple mais
c'est pas un reproche c'est censé 150
300 800
on l'a passé à Bercy donc on a mais il
faut qu'on se documente ça pour dire où
sont les trous est-ce que c'est un cas
particulier ou est-ce que c'est toute
une filière qui est en train de prendre
son risque donc on est en train de
travailler pour ajuster le dispositif et
pour faire en sorte que l'on soit plus
le plus près de la réalité on aura des
trous dans la raquette on va ça me sur
la Drôme j'en ai parlé l'autre jour je
vous ai même cité d'ailleurs aussi je me
souviens bien les parlementaires nous
ont nous ont sollicité là la question là
il y a le dispositif simplement le
statut hybride a dit votre collègue de
l'Assemblée nationale madame Antoine a
dit statut hybride oui le statut hybride
fait que ça rentre pas dans la case mais
globalement ça rentrerait dans le
dispositif ce qui est pas le cas d'un
certain nombre aujourd'hui de filières
donc on y travaille je reconnais avec
modestic c'est tellement complexe cette
affaire là mais c'est plutôt le guichet
pour nous pour ces filières là il me
semble que c'est plutôt dans le cadre du
guichet qui rentrerait au-delà des 13
énergos intensifs mais là c'est plutôt
les grandes industries agroalimentaires
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire madame
la Présidente vous remercions bon merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre je sais
qu'il y a des frustrations dans les
réponses mais au moins les questions ont
été posées enregistrées et je pense que
vos services pour nous répondre par
écrit et je vous donne rendez-vous dans
l'hémicycle pour le PLF qu'on a
finalement assez peu abordé